Für's Zuschauen!
Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch. Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch.
Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch.
Ja, mach mal Mikro an.
Was?
Na endlich mal was.
Damit das mal jemand mitkriegt mit dem Skandal.
Ja, hier ist Hauskrach, Holger, die Liebe ist beendet.
Ziege.
So läuft's nun gar nicht.
Tim, Ziege.
Na echt.
Ja, und sie Frauen anrufen lassen immer an, ne?
Oh, Tim.
Oh, Holger.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
116, Chaosradio 116 im Studio Frank und Tim.
Guten Abend.
Ja, hallo, guten Tag. Es klingt total komisch, was die Mikros wieder ganz merkwürdig übersteuert oder was.
Genau, ich hab meins untersteuert und deins übersteuert.
Das ist schön, dass du in meinem Mikrofon so viel Aufmerksamkeit zollst.
Ja, irgendjemand muss hier irgendjemandem Aufmerksamkeit zollen. Du hältst das ja nicht für nötig.
Ähm, ich bin in der Regentonne.
Ah, gut, okay.
Also hier ist der Chaos Computer Club mit Holgi aus der Regentonne. Und wir wollen euch heute ein bisschen ähm... Nachher sinkt ja uns auch noch was vor. Und heute wollen wir ein wenig über Ortungssysteme reden und informieren, soweit uns das gelingt. Ortungssysteme, das bedeutet Satellitengestützte, Navigation vor allem, aber nicht unbedingt nur. Wir wollen einen Blick ein bisschen auf die Geschichte werfen, wie sich das alles entwickelt hat, aber natürlich vor allem, was heute so rauskommt, weil das gerade eines der heißen Themen ist. Im Internet, in der ganzen IT-Branche, ihr habt es sicherlich schon mal gehört, Geo-Tagging, Geocaching, generell Location-Based Services. Holger sieht schon eine Schnute. Hast du schon mal gehört von solchen Sachen? Hast du schon mal benutzt?
Geocaching wollten wir immer mal machen. Wir wollten immer mal die Momo und ich, das war eine Kollegin von mir. Wir haben hier morgens zusammen Radio gemacht ein paar Jahre lang. Wir hatten immer überlegt, ob wir nicht mal ein bisschen Geocaching gehen sollten. Wir haben gesagt, hey, das ist eine total lustige Sache, können wir machen mit Hörern Geocaching. Hat hier in der Redaktion wieder keine Sau verstanden, wie immer. Sind ja alles Journalisten.
Sagt das aber nicht.
Aber Geocaching ist mittlerweile wirklich...
Wir sind gerade alle in Klärchens Ballhaus einsaufen. Wir können machen, was wir wollen.
Ich glaube, in Klärchens Ballhaus gibt es auch einen Geocaching. Geocaching ist mittlerweile ein richtiger Volkssport geworden. Man trifft ja die unmöglichsten Leute auf. Vielleicht sollten wir das nachher noch ein bisschen genauer erklären.
Genau, das ist eine der Sachen, auf die wir kommen. Ich wollte auch jetzt, bevor wir zu tief ins Thema einsteigen, noch ein paar kleine Announcements rauslassen. Wir haben ein kleines Experiment. Es gibt ja seit einiger Zeit zum Chaosradio auch das zugehörige Wiki unter wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de und dort gibt es für jede Sendung auch eine dedizierte Seite. In diesem Fall halt Chaosradio 116, ist auch auf der Hauptseite verlinkt. Und da gibt es dann wiederum so eine Unterseite slash Timeline, das findet ihr dort. Und das ist so der Versuch, während der Sendung quasi schon Kapitelmarken zu bilden für die Sendung, sodass wir später von der Aufzeichnung eine mit Kapitelmarken versehene Version der Sendung publizieren können.
Also mit anderen Worten soll jemand mitschreiben, wann immer wir irgendwas sagen?
Naja, stenne. Es geht vor allem erstmal um die grobe Kapitelaufteilung. Also wenn ein Nachrichtenblock beginnt, oder ein Werbeblock beginnt, oder wenn ein neues Thema aufgeschlagen wird. Das ist natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen im Rückblick. Aber auch wenn interessante URLs fallen gelassen werden, dann kann man sie dort einblenden, weil wenn man das Ganze dann im MPEG-4-Audio-Format macht, kann man solche URLs direkt mitten in die Datei einbauen.
Wie ist das denn jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn jemand das erst macht, wenn er den Mitschnitt hört und das im Mitschnitt noch nicht drin ist?
Man kann das jetzt schon live während der Sendung machen, was vielleicht den meisten einfacher fällt. Oder eben dann später, wenn man den ersten MP3-Mitschnitt hat, aus dem Podcast zum Beispiel. Und das wird dann eben auch erst ein paar Tage später gemacht werden können. Ich denke mal, ich gucke mir das in einer Woche dann nochmal an, was sozusagen dabei rausgekommen ist. Und dann machen wir da einfach mal was draus. Das ist alles noch nicht so super automatisiert. Ich hätte auch lieber so eine kleine finnige Web-Applikation. Ich weiß ja nicht, vielleicht gibt es ja unter unseren Hörern ein paar Kessel Rails, Ruby on Rails Entwickler zum Beispiel. Da sollte sich das eigentlich schnell machen lassen, dass man so ein kleines User Interface hat, wo man sagt, jetzt ist was tolles passiert und die URL ist und das Kapitel ist zack, bumm. Und dann wirft man das damit rein, ohne dass man jetzt so mit Wiki editieren und Tabellen formatieren ist ja auch nicht jedermanns Sache. Aber haben wir gerade nicht, deswegen probieren wir es erstmal so. Und wenn das ankommt, machen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr.
Chaosradio 116, Ordnungssysteme unser Thema.
Genau und ich hab noch zwei andere kurze Hinweise.
Kleine Anzeigen.
Kleine Anzeigen, genau. Am Wochenende gibt es noch eine CCC-Veranstaltung in Darmstadt. Wer Lust hat daran teilzunehmen, die MRM CD, also Meta Rhein Main heißt das, Chaos Days ist drei Tage lockeres Konferenzprogramm. Das ist dieses Wochenende. Da findet ihr Informationen auf ccc.de. Und für die Leute, die darüber nachdenken, beim 23.3. bei unserem großen Kongress Ende des Jahres noch einen Vortrag einzureichen. Die sollten sich sputen, weil Mitte September ist unsere Deadline. Informationen dazu auf dem blog events.ccc.de. So, aber jetzt können wir auch mal hier einsteigen ins Thema. Und zwar in die Navigation und in die Ortung. Und vielleicht erst mal ein Blick so zurück, wo das alles herkommt. Die ersten wirklichen Ortungsproblematiken. Gab es natürlich immer und überall, aber besonders schwerwiegend war das immer in der Schifffahrt. Und da haben sich eigentlich auch so die ersten Ortungssysteme entwickelt. Was war denn der erste Frank?
Ganz am Anfang waren natürlich handgemalte Karten. Also man hat versucht sich an Sonnenstand und Sternen so grob zu orientieren und festzustellen, wo man ist. Da die Frühschifffahrt weitestgehend küstennah war, hat man versucht sich von Landmarke zu Landmarke zu hangeln. So mit visueller Navigation ist deswegen auch nur tagsüber gefahren. Und nachts war dann halt immer blöd, weil konnte man halt raustreiben. Und dann die ersten großen Durchbrüche waren dann der Kompass, mit dem man dann zumindest die Himmelsrichtung auch bei schlechtem Wetter feststellen konnte, was sonst ein bisschen schwierig war. Dann ein bisschen später kamen halt, also eine Weile später kamen halt solche Dinge wie Astrolabium, also so Sternen-Navigationshilfsmittel und halt der Sextant dazu, mit dem man seine Position zumindest halbwegs genau feststellen kann, wenn man halt Sonne gesehen hat. Und zum Sextanten umzugehen war halt schon ein bisschen schwierig, da gab es irgendwie auch eine richtige Ausbildung für. Man muss halt die Höhe der Sonne über den Horizont messen, weil halt auf einem schwankenden Schiff nicht immer so ganz trivial ist.
Ja, man muss es vor allen Dingen zu einer definierten Zeit auch messen.
Genau, man muss es halt zu einer genauen Zeit tun, man muss halt deine Uhrzeit genau wissen. Und damit kann man halt seine Position so ansatzweise bestimmen.
Längengrad?
Genau, nicht den Breitengrad.
Wie funktioniert denn eigentlich so ein Sextant?
Breitengrad, nicht Längengrad.
So.
Wie war's? Irgendjemand hat bestimmt die WGP, die er auch kennt. Wenn wir einen Hörer haben, der uns erklären kann, wie ein Sextant funktioniert, dann rufen wir doch bitte mal an.
Genau, aber grundsätzlich geht es ja darum, die Sonne über dem Horizont anzupeilen und aus den daraus gemessenen Werten, Rückschlüsse zu führen auf die Position. Aber das wäre in der Tat mal cool, falls irgendjemand von euch...
Breitengrad. Du brauchst den Horizont Sonne, den Winkel von Breitengrad und die Zeit ab Greenwich für den Längengrad.
Damit du weißt, wie weit du von Greenwich weggehst.
Das kannst du über die Zeit.
Eure Frank-Mahn hier mit ihren Fingern liegend.
Eine typische Handbewegung.
Sechs Tanten erklären.
Kann vielleicht mal jemand hier anrufen und uns einen Sechs Tanten erklären, bitte? 03317797110.
Also Wikipedia kriegen wir selber.
Am besten wir...
Genau, jemand, der tatsächlich noch eine Sechs-Tanten-Ausbildung bekommen hat, wäre doch sehr interessant.
Sehbären, wir wollen Sehbären.
Sehbären.
Genau, mit so einem Papagei auf der Schuhe.
Der die ganze Zeit dazwischenquatscht.
Ja, einäugig bitte.
Gut, also so war die Seefahrt halt lange Zeit. Genauer gesagt bis eigentlich zum zweiten Weltkrieg. Im zweiten Weltkrieg gab es dann Entwicklungen von Funkparsystemen, mit denen man seine Position halt etwas genauer bestimmen konnte. Also die Deutschen waren da relativ weit vorne mal wieder. Wir haben Sechs-Tanten erklären.
Ich glaube wir haben Sechs-Tanten erklären.
Der Dirk? Ja, der Dirk ist hier.
Kannst du einen Sechs-Tanten erklären?
Ich kann einen Sechs-Tanten nicht unbedingt erklären.
Warum rufst du dann an?
Weil das mit dem Längengrad Breitengrad Problematik ding.
Na leg mal los.
Also, wenn man das mit dem Sechs-Tanten unter Höhe der Sonne hinkriegt, kann man seinen Breitengrad bestimmen. Das heißt, wie weit bin ich vom Äquator weg? Was ewig ein Problem war, war den Längengrad zu bestimmen.
Ja, aber das hat man doch gesagt.
Und das mit der Uhr auch?
Ja, erklär einfach mal, was du weißt.
Weil man dafür extrem genaugehende Uhren brauchte, um festzustellen, wie weit die jetzige Zeit vom Heimathafenzeit entfernt ist. Und wenn man diese Zeit hat, weiß man, es hat einen Längengrad gekannt. Und das war, glaube ich, bis 1700 irgendwas ein großes Problem.
Okay, aber du hast noch keinen Sextanten in der Hand gehabt?
Nee.
Und du bist auch kein Seebär?
Und du hast auch kein Papagei?
Nee. Okay, dann können wir zur Bestimmung keinen Schweißen sagen.
Vielleicht finden wir ja noch einen Seebär.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der einen Sextanten bedienen kann und uns erklären kann, wie genau das funktioniert?
Keine Wikipedia-Vorleser.
Aber weit kam er ja nicht mit dem Sextanten.
Wie gesagt, nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wurden dann Funkparsysteme entwickelt. Was man da getan hat, war, man hat halt an Stellen, wo man große Sender, also wirklich große Sender aufstellen konnte, es getan und die Position dieser Sender halt vermessen.
Was ist denn groß?
Na so 400 Meter hohe Antennen, also wo die Antennen, also die aktive Antenne 400 Meter hoch ist, also nicht breit, sondern hoch. Und es gab halt mehrere Verfahren, die ersten Verfahren waren mit Richtungspeilung, also man hat die Richtung zu dem Sender gepeilt, aber das ist halt ziemlich aufwendig und schwierig, weil die Richtanteile auch relativ groß sind auf den Frequenzen, die man verwendet hat. Und deswegen hat man dann halt das sogenannte Hyperbill-Verfahren entwickelt, wo man halt das Signal aus mehreren Sendern überlagert und aus den Dopplereffekten seine Position rausbekommt. Und da gab es dann halt auch so Karten, wo die Wellen, Berge und Täter von diesen Dopplereffekten eingezeichnet waren. Und daraus konnte man dann sozusagen einstellen an diesem Gerät, bis sich halt das Signal überlagert hat. Und dann konnte man aus drei Sendern seine Positionen feststellen. Die waren relativ genau für sechs Tantenverhältnisse. Also man kann da auf einige hundert Meter Genauigkeit mit. So das bekannteste Verfahren, früher war halt DECA, nach der englischen Firma war das.
DECA Records ist da ja auch ein Clip-Spring, das hat tatsächlich was damit zu tun.
Ich wollte nur einen dummen Spruch machen. Nee, nee, wäre noch nie mal ein dummer Spruch gewesen. Und das Verfahren, was sich dann so ziemlich bis zum Schluss durchgesetzt hat, war halt Loran C. Ist immer noch in Betrieb, war ursprünglich von den von den Ami Militärs betrieben. Und ist mittlerweile so unter internationaler Kontrolle und wird immer noch betrieben so als eine Art Backup-Verfahren, um halt im Falle des Ausfalls von GPS oder falls der GPS-Empfänger auf dem Schiff nicht geht oder was auch immer, man halt noch ein zuverlässiges, bodengestütztes Navigationsverfahren hat.
Was heißt denn hyperbel Verfahren? Also ich hab's, ja ok, aber es hat ja im Prinzip was mit der Messung der Laufzeiten zu tun.
Genau, also es ist ein Laufzeitmessungsverfahren auf der Basis des Doppelleffekts zwischen den Signalen.
Doppelleffekt ist, dieses Krankenwagen kommt von rechts, lüla, lüla und dann fährt er weg und dann ist der Ton niedriger. Das heißt, je nachdem, ob sich das Ziel von einem weg bewegt oder hin bewegt, ist die Frequenz anders. Und danach kann man das eben messen. Und dieses Verfahren ist dann ja im Prinzip auch die Basis für die heutigen Satellitensysteme.
Also die ursprünglichen Systeme, die als erstes mit der Signalüberlagerung gearbeitet haben, waren interessanterweise von der deutschen Luftwaffe im Zweiten Weltkrieg entwickelt worden, um halt England präziser bombardieren zu können.
Ha, wer hat es erfunden?
Die Deutschen. Ja, natürlich, immer. Wahrscheinlich gab es noch andere Vorläuferverfahren, aber die, was die halt getan haben, die haben halt an der Kanalküste im besetzten Frankreich und im besetzten Norwegen Sender aufgestellt, die halt ein relativ schmales Signal gesendet haben. Was heißt ein schmales Signal? Also ein relativ stark gebündeltes Signal. Der hat in dem Flugzeug, also jetzt vereinfacht gesprochen, zwei Empfänger dran, einen für den Sender in Frankreich, einen für den Sender in Norwegen. Und die haben halt zeitlich versetzt Düts gesendet. Und zwar immer so versetzt, dass wenn die genau übereinander waren, also wenn er sozusagen beide mit derselben Signalstärke gehört hat, dann war er halt über dem Ziel. Das heißt, dann hat er sozusagen Düt gehört. Und dann wussten sie, dass sie über dem Ziel sind. Und damit konnten sie halt relativ präzise, also ich habe keine Daten über die Genauigkeit gelesen, aber es war wohl doch einigermaßen präzise für damalige Verhältnisse und haben damit halt auch in der Nacht halt relativ präzise bombardieren können, auch über komplett verdunkelten Land.
Also man hat nicht 10 Kilometer daneben gehauen, sondern...
Nur ein Kilometer oder so. Also der Drang halt irgendwie präzise zu wissen, wo man ist, ist halt natürlich spezifisch im Militär halt irgendwie sehr stark. Also mit der Entwicklung der Raketentechnik gab es halt natürlich den Bedarf, relativ genau zu wissen, wo diese Rakete jetzt hinfliegt. Und man hat halt alle möglichen Dinge entwickelt dafür. Ganz am Anfang waren halt so Tricker-Navigationssysteme. Das heißt, hat man halt einen Kreiselkompass drin gehabt und eine Kurvenscheibe, mit der das Flugprofil bestimmt wurde. Das ist also tatsächlich so ein Stück Metall, was sich so dreht und sich langsam weiter dreht. Und über so Fühler an diesem Metall wurden dann halt hinten die Lenkflossen an der Rakete geändert. Das heißt, das war sozusagen ein rein zeitgestörter Verfahren. Man hat halt angenommen, die Rakete fliegt halt mit konstantem Schub. Muss also bei konstantem Schub ungefähr nach Zeit N an dieser und jener Stelle sein. Also ändern wir jetzt hier mal den Vortrieb. Das war halt wie die deutsche V2 gesteuert wurde. Und Kreisekompass hat das Ding halt in der richtigen Richtung erhalten. Und naja, als es dann an Intercontinentalraketen ging, wurde dann natürlich ein bisschen knifflig.
Also im Prinzip war diese Raketensteuerung so eine reine ballistische Geschichte. Man hat einfach gesagt, wo müssen wir langschießen?
Nee, die konnten das Flugprofil schon ändern. Die konnten die Steuerflossen von dem Ding wirklich schon steuern, zeitabhängig. Die wussten halt, bei dem Schub ist das Ding dann so weit, also jetzt mal runter.
Sie hatten im Prinzip so eine klare Flughurve. Oder war es so richtig hoch und dann fliegt sie irgendwie eine Weile und dann wieder runter?
Genau, sie konnten auch unterschiedliche Flughöhen damit einstellen.
So auch mal unter einer Brücke durch?
Marschflug zwei, Marschfortz. Die Militärtechnik war halt der wesentliche Treiber für diese ganzen Navigationsgeschichten. Als die Interkontinentarraketen kamen, die tausende von Kilometern fliegen konnten, mussten sie die auch einigermaßen genau ins Ziel kriegen. Und das war halt schwierig.
Und was dann passiert ist, erfahren wir nach den Nachrichten. Und vor den Nachrichten, da erklärt Axel uns noch wie ein Sextant-Funk. Ich wusste, dass ich mich auf dich verlassen kann, Axel.
Übrigens noch ganz kurz zu euren letzten Sachen. Intercontinentale Raketen fliegen immer noch ballistische Kurven. Nur die Wiedereintrittskörper sind dann gesteuert. Aber gut, Sextant, folgende Idee.
Entschuldigung, kurze Nachfrage. Wie gesteuert die Wiedereintrittskörper?
Die Wiedereintrittskörper, also die eigentlichen Sprengköpfe sind erst gesteuert.
Das heißt, die Rakete...
Die Rakete selber fliegt eine ballistische Kurve. Die wird vorgegeben. Das heißt, es wird eine gewisse Flughöhe vorgegeben und eine Abschlussrichtung, damit ist klar, in welche Richtung sie fliegt und wo sie primär ihr Ziel erreichen soll. Und die Wiedereintrittskörper, nachdem der angetriebene Flug der Rakete beendet ist, sprengt sich ja sozusagen die Spitze auf und man hat dynamisch steuerbare Wiedereintrittskörper. Und die werden im Nachhinein dann erst auf das Ziel gesteuert. Das heißt, die Rakete explodiert, weiß ich nicht, also explodiert, ist übertrieben, verteilt sich in Schlachtmichtod ein paar 100 Kilometer Höhe, 100, 200 Kilometer Höhe. Und die Wiedereintrittskörper sind dann erst in der Lage, ihr Ziel anzugreifen.
Wie stelle ich mir einen solchen Wiedereintrittskörper vor? Wie eine kleine Rakete oder eine Bombe oder?
Wie eine Bombe.
Wie eine gelenkte Bombe. Wie eine lasergelenkte Bombe, muss man sich das vorstellen.
Das ist halt so ein Kegelförmiges...
Das ist im Prinzip ein Kegelförmiges Projektil. Also im Prinzip ein Projektil. Vorne spitz, eiförmig. Wie Herr Schukowsky mal sagte, ein Ei mit einer Spitze dran. Und da sind wie auch bei der V2 Steuerflächen hinten dran. Und die Steuerflächen heutzutage natürlich eher anders gesteuert. Also nicht mehr ballistisch und nicht mehr trägert gesteuert. Ob die Trägertsteuerung immer noch mit drin ist. Zielen dann sozusagen die vorprogrammierte Koordinate an. Die Rakete selber, die also in Großteil des Weges zurücklegt, ist immer noch ballistisch. Bloß dass die Zielgenauigkeit bei der Ballistik heutzutage auch schon ein bisschen besser ist.
Okay, aber eigentlich hast du ja wegen des Sextanten angerufen, oder? Ja, eigentlich wegen des Sextanten.
Okay, dann hast du jetzt noch zwei Minuten. Ich bringe zwei Punkte mittels Spiegel in Übereinstimmung. Ich ziele mit einem Auge geradeaus gegen den Horizont und habe einen drehbaren Spiegel. Und mit diesem drehbaren Spiegel versuche ich, einen sternbekannter Höhe oder auch die Sonnebekannter Höhe so lange zu verschieben, bis sie genau auf der Horizontlinie liegt. Damit habe ich genau die Höhe der Sonne, beispielsweise zur Mittagszeit, und weiß damit, in welcher geografischen Breite ich mich befinde.
Sag mal, hast du einen Vogel?
Der hat einen Papagei. Ja, ein Papagei ist trotzdem ein ziemlich quietschendes Tier. Das kann ich leider nicht abstellen, er hat keinen Schalter. Wir haben eine Softwareversion 1.2 einspielen. Das heißt, ich habe einen, wie gesagt, und wenn ich den Spiegel so lange gedreht habe, bis die Sonne auf der Horizontlinie aufsitzt, habe ich genau den Winkel, den die Sonne gegenüber dem Erdboden hat. Und damit habe ich die scheinbare Höhe der Sonne gemessen. Was übrigens auch mit Sternen geht. Ich kann auch damit die scheinbare Höhe eines Sterns messen. Und da ich weiß, aus Tabellen, wo mein Stern zu welchem Zeitpunkt ist, kann ich damit meine Position bestimmen. Zwingende Voraussetzungen weiterhin dazu ist natürlich eine hochgenau gehende Uhr. Daher ja der Kollege, der den Preis der Englischen Akademie gewonnen hat mit seiner hochgenauen Uhr. Wie hieß der denn?
Eigentlich war der Schmied oder sowas.
Der war Zimmermann. Die Abflugabflüge habe ich aus Holz gebaut. Holz hatte keine Wärmeausdehnung. Hatte keinen Wärmeausdehnungs-Gereffizienten. Und damit war das Problem der Ausdehnung, Verlängerung des Pendels. Eine erste Uhr war ja noch eine Pendelüber. Verlängerung des Pendels und damit Veränderung der Schwingungsfrequenz ausgehoben.
Zeit ist auch so ein Thema.
Das ist aber noch mal eine eigene Sendung.
Das ist aber wirklich wert für eine eigene Sendung. Der Sextant ist also primär ein Winkelmessgerät. Was die Höhe eines Sterns über der Ebene messen kann. Also die Höhe eines bekannten leuchtenden Punktes über der Ebene messen kann. Und mithilfe dieser genauen Winkelmessung kann ich ja die Position bestimmen. Wenn ich also weiß, 12 Uhr muss die Sonne eigentlich am Zenit stehen. Wenn sie aber nicht am Zenit steht, sondern an der anderen Stelle, kann ich damit die Höhe der Sonne messen und kann damit messen, wo ich bin.
Super, bist du denn ein Seebär?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß es gar nicht, aber aus der Messtechnik.
Vielen Dank, Axel.
Ja, super Erklärung, vielen Dank.
Ja, über das Hyperbole-Verfahren hatten wir vorhin, wissen wir, weil die Signalgleiche Zonen Hyperbole waren beim Loran-Verfahren.
Was?
Die, was?
Ah, weil die Signalgleiche Zonen, okay.
Die Zonen gleicher Weisung waren Hyperbole und die Schnittpunkte zweier Hyperbole ließen sich dann als Position bestimmen. Oder die Schnittpunkte dreier Hyperbole beim Loran-Verfahren.
Super, dann hätten wir das ja auch noch im Kasten.
Hier ist Nina Hagen.
Gut, talerseits. Hier ist Markus Kafka.
Was ist los? Ist das Mel Beats?
Hier ist Boss von Boss House.
Der kleine Mann hier ist der Sarah Kuttner. Okay, mein Name ist Bushido.
Das ist die Fritz Music Tours. Zieht euch rein.
Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Von Landstein bis Zied. Von Depeche Mode bis Agro Berlin.
Von Iggy Pop bis Techno.
Auf den Spuren der Popmusikgeschichte Berlins. Mit dem Bus durch die Stadt. Fritz Music Tours Berlin. Immer samstags.
Immer samstags.
Mehr Infos.
fritz.de Und natürlich im Radio.
2 nach halb 11.
Fritz. Info.
Die Bundeswehr wird mehr als die bisher genannten 1200 Soldaten in den Nahen Osten schicken, das sagte Verteidigungsminister Jung in einem Interview. Dabei betonte er erneut, dass die deutschen Marinesoldaten bei ihrer Mission gegen den Waffenschmuggel auch in Kampfhandlungen verstrickt werden könnten. Zur Dauer des Einsatzes wollte Jung sich nicht festlegen. Die Nutzung von Netzen der Anbieter von Strom, Gas und Mobilfunk soll billiger werden. Die Bundesnetzagentur verpflichtete mehrere Unternehmen, ihre Preise zu senken. So soll unter anderem der Energieversorger EON bis zu 16 Prozent niedrigere Durchleitungsgebühren verlangen dürfen als beantragt. Außerdem soll EON in einigen Regionen die Preise für die Durchleitung von Gas bis zu 11 Prozent senken. Die deutschen Stadtwerke erwarten zum Jahreswechsel dennoch einen Anstieg der Strompreise. Das Hamburger Unternehmen Conergy will in der leerstehenden Schiffabrikhalle in Frankfurt oder Solartechnik produzieren. Mittelfristig könnten bis zu 1000 Arbeitsplätze entstehen, berichteten mehrere Zeitungen unter Berufung auf einen Unternehmenssprecher. Förderungsanträge für das Vorhaben seien bereits gestellt. Mehrere Billigfluganbieter haben die Planung für den Großflughafen Berlin Brandenburg international kritisiert. Neun Billigfluglinien drohten heute gemeinsam mit ihrem Rückzug aus Berlin. In einem Appell heißt es, die Planung für den Flughafen seien nur auf die traditionellen und teuren Fluggesellschaften wie Lufthansa ausgerichtet. Andere internationale Flughäfen würden den Billigfliegern eigene, abgetrennte Terminals zur Verfügung stellen. Dies sei in Berlin nicht der Fall. Mit dem Wetter ja auch heute Nacht soll es regnen. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 13 bis 10 Grad. Am Tag wird es wolkig, aber auch mal heiter, bei Höchstwerten um 21 Grad. A13 Dresden Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Ortrand und Ruhland gibt es immer noch Behinderungen wegen Bergungsarbeiten nach einem Unfall. Ansonsten überall eine gute Fahrt.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1? Dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Chaosradio 116 mit Ortungssystem.
Aus dem Internet. Ich kann's dir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen. Wie schon im Chat korrekt bemerkt wurde, ist das eigentlich sogar so ein Flash-Movie, wo ich das irgendwie rausgezogen habe. Da hat halt irgendjemand 1000 Windows, Audio-Recorder, was weiß ich, System-Sounds gleichzeitig gespielt. Das ist auch visuell ganz interessant. Hab ich aber jetzt glaube ich nicht mehr so rumfliegen müssen.
Ich hab noch einen Jingle rausgesucht passend.
Es folgt nun ein Witz für Freunde der nicht euklidischen Geometrie.
Ups, mein Ball ist umgeklebt.
Und am Radio?
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das heißt.
Ja, nee, war passend.
Sehr gut. Also zurück zur nicht euklidischen Geometrie.
War das nicht vielleicht mit Hyperbeln und so?
Also kommen wir mal kurz zurück zu, wie es ging mit dem GPS los. Also das mit dem T-Hat hat natürlich nicht nur interkontinentale Raketen, wo halt die ballistische Stauung so halbwegs funktioniert ist, sondern es gab dann halt auch die ersten Marschlohkörper. Marschlohkörper sind halt so kleine, also relativ kleine, sprengstofftransportierende Flugkörper, die...
Kleines, süßes, sprengstoff...
Marschlohkörperchen.
Genau. Die halt einigermaßen tief fliegen und dadurch halt irgendwie auch unter dem Radar fliegen. Das heißt also, die so tief fliegen, dass man das Radar nicht sieht. Die ersten Navigationssysteme für diese Dinge waren halt auch so mit so Kreisekompassen und halt diesem sogenannten Dead Reckoning-Verfahren.
Was?
Dead Reckoning?
Genau, so heißt der Trickers Navigation auf Englisch.
Dürfte sich aber mal wieder sehr kompliziert aus, finde ich.
Na gut, lass mich mal kurz zum Punkt kommen.
Gerne.
Diese Marschle-Körper haben halt über verschiedene Navigationsverfahren versucht, zum Ziel zu finden. Eines davon war unter anderem Bild-Matching, also die hatten eine Kamera drinnen und haben halt Bilder gemacht und haben halt versucht, das mit anderen vorgespeicherten Bildern abzugleichen. Also wenn sie halt durch so einen Tal gefifft sind, haben sie halt versucht, durch dieses Tal halt optisch durchzufinden. Also lustigerweise mit so, ich glaube, 68.000 Prozessoren hatten sie damals drin. Es funktionierte halt nicht immer besonders gut, vor allem nicht im Winter, weil dann änderte sich halt einfach mal die Optik anders. Dann haben sie halt mit Radar versucht, Radar ist blöd, weil Radar sieht der Gegner und sozusagen das Prinzip von so einem Muffler-Körper ist ja, dass er möglichst unsichtbar ist. Und der Durchbruch, also die durchbrechende Idee war dann halt, ein satellitenbasiertes Navigationssystem zu bauen. Da gab es halt längere Experimente.
Wo befinden wir uns denn jetzt eigentlich? In den 70er Jahren?
Wir befinden uns jetzt im Mitte der 70er Jahre. Die Idee, ein satellitenbasiertes Navigationssystem zu bauen, gab es halt schon sehr lange. Aber 1978 fing halt die Entwicklung richtig an. Also ich glaube schon zwei Jahre vorher, aber 1978 wurden halt die ersten Test-Satelliten gebaut. Und so nach und nach gab es dann mehrere Fortschritte bei den Verfahren. Am Anfang war das halt noch sehr ähnlich, den alten Funknavigationsverfahren. GPS selber hat damit nur noch relativ wenig zu tun. Man bezog sich da halt eine ganze Weile hin und so erst eigentlich ab Anfang der 90er war so ein experimenteller Testbetrieb richtig möglich. In 1995 war das System dann komplett. GPS steht halt für Global Positioning System und wurde halt, wie gesagt, vom amerikanischen Militär entwickelt, primär, um halt ihre Marschflugkörper ans Ziel zu bringen. Das war halt der eigentliche Sinn des ganzen Unterfangs.
Das war ja bei der Teflon-Fanne nicht anders.
Genau, die Teflon-Fanne sollte auch die Marschflugkörper ans Ziel bringen.
Klettverschluss.
Das ist eigentlich sowieso fast alles Militär.
Na, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Doch, doch, doch.
Nun, das Schöne am GPS war halt, dass zu der Zeit, als es dann halt wirklich mal freigeschaltet wurde und halt in den Regelbetrieb ging, war halt der Kalte Krieg vorbei. Und das ist halt so ein bisschen blöd, halt, wenn man dann halt solche immensen Ausgaben wie für so ein weltumspannendes Satellitensystem mit 24 Satelliten, die halt benötigt werden, nicht so richtig rechtfertigen kann und dann kam es halt auf die Idee, mit könnte man auch zivil verwenden.
Meinst du, dass sie da wirklich erst Anfang der 90er Jahre drauf gekommen sind?
Ja, also die tatsächlich, der wirkliche Einbau eines zivilen Systems wurde eigentlich wirklich erst nach dem Ende des Kalten Krieges wirklich forciert. Also das war halt vorher schon immer mal wieder so diskutiert, aber die hatte offensichtlich nicht sehr Priorität wieder nach. Und Militär ist halt Militär, die haben das zivile Verfahren halt erstmal dramatisch verschlechtert. Also die GPS besteht halt aus zwei verschiedenen Navigationssystems, einmal das militärische und einmal das zivile. Und am Anfang war halt das zivile so künstlich verschlechtert mit einem Verfahren, was ich selective availability nannte, dass man es so naja so grob auf 80 bis 100 Meter genau benutzen konnte. Und das reicht halt nicht aus für gute Autonavigation, so 80 bis 100 Meter reicht halt aus, um Schiff zu steuern, so grob, aber für Straßennavigation ist das halt nicht ausreichend. Und damit, das lief dann halt ein paar Jahre so, dass es halt keine genaue Positionierung gab, also GPS haben halt irgendwelche Freaks verwendet, die halt irgendwie durch die Berge geschlichen sind. Also das kann mich noch erinnern, das erste GPS-Gerät hat der glaube ich Pavel mal gekauft, irgendwie in Japan. Nee, das war halt so, naja, so eine kleine Teflon-Bratpfanne. Und da hat er halt so einen Kasten drunter und ist halt so dick und groß und schwer und hat halt irgendwie eine Batterielaufzeit von glaube ich vier Stunden auf sechs so großen dicken Batterien, also das war halt nicht besonders beeindruckend. Aber er konnte nach einer Weile dann doch tatsächlich eine Position anzeigen.
Aber eine Weile heißt, eine Viertelstunde muss ja schon seine Nase in die Luft halten.
Also das war halt so der damalige Stand der Dinge halt so.
Okay, lass uns auch mal kurz auf die Technik zu sprechen kommen. Also Satellitensystem heißt, man schickt eine größere Teilmenge von Satelliten in ein oder mehrere Orbits. Wie viele Satelliten sind nötig bei GPS? 24, richtig?
Also 24 Satelliten sind nötig, um die Erde komplett abzudecken.
Aber dann hat man noch ein paar mehr in der Luft, falls mal einer ein Hunter fällt?
Man hat halt immer noch sogenannte Spares, also Ersatzsatelliten, weil die Dinger gehen halt auch mal kaputt. Also die durchschnittliche Lebenszeit ist jetzt glaube ich so siebeneinhalb Jahre projektiert, meistens halten sie dann doch länger.
Woran gehen die eigentlich kaputt?
Woran Satelliten halt so kaputt gegen Mikrometeoriten, Solarzelle verschlissen, weiß nicht, was sonst noch an Elektronik da dran ist, die halt kaputt gehen kann. Sendeleistung des Senders nimmt ab, also da gibt es halt eine Vielzahl von...
Ist ja auch nicht schön da draußen mit der Strahlung und so.
Und immerzu.
Letztes Mal als ich da war, ich sagte ja nie wieder.
Und Meteoriten und so.
Aber sie haben halt noch mehr draußen, also ich hab es auch mal vorhin hier, was war das? Ich glaube 31 fliegen jetzt tatsächlich um die Erde, das heißt sie haben immer noch ein bisschen Luft und man sieht also auch mehr als man als man braucht, aber kann auch nicht schaden. Hauptsache das System ist halbwegs ausfallsicher, aber man muss jetzt, wieviel, vier, muss man mindestens sehen, damit man eine korrekte Höhe und Position bekommt.
Genau, also um halt irgendwie eine korrekte Exzepsionanzettposition zu erhalten. Warum ist das nicht wirklich genau? Das ist prinzipbedingt, also was, wie halt GPS funktioniert, ist eigentlich ziemlich faszinierend. Jeder dieser GPS-Satelliten hat eine Atomuhr an Bord und sendet das genaue Zeitsignal dieser Atomuhr. Und die Positionsbestimmung passiert auf der Basis einer Laufzeitreferenz dieses Signals. Also der eine Satellit ist halt näher dran, der andere ist weiter weg. Und daraus kann man dann halt eine Gleichung aufstellen, wenn man weiß, mit welchem Zeitunterschied das Signal von diesen Satelliten eintrifft.
Das heißt, ich müsste doch eigentlich auf einen Zentimeter genauer?
Zumindest theoretisch. Aber es ist halt so, dass die, es gibt halt mehrere Hindernungsfaktoren. Der erste Faktor ist, dass das Signal halt mit relativ geringer Sendeleistung gesendet wird. Das heißt also man, und hat eine Netto-Datenrate von 50 Bit pro Sekunde. Also das ist halt extrem langsam so. Das heißt also man kriegt halt nicht so richtig doll viele Bits pro Sekunde darunter. Zum anderen ist es so, dass es halt atmosphärische Störungen gibt, die halt die Genauigkeit dieses Signals einschränken. Man muss sich das Signal auch nicht vorstellen wie so ein Morse-Code, sondern es ist halt so ein Rauschen. Und es ist so ein Spread-Spektrum-Verfahren, wo halt auf vielen Frequenzen gleichzeitig oder nacheinander gesendet wird und zwar alle Satelliten gleichzeitig. Und man rechnet sich dann halt mit einem so genannten P-Code, nämlich so einer Tabelle, in der drin steht, wann welches Bit, also auf welcher Frequenz, was bedeutet, rechnet man sich dann tatsächlich erst das Signal daraus, um halt auch Störungen zu umgehen.
Also Spread-Spektrum heißt, dass die nicht auf einer Frequenz senden, sondern dass sie auf mehreren Frequenzen ihre Informationen parallel senden, damit es nicht so anfällig ist gegen irgendetwas, was jetzt eine spezifische Frequenz rausfiltert. Und auch wechselnd.
Also auch wechselnd. Also das ist halt nicht, die springen halt durch dieses Spektrum durch, das heißt, die sind halt ein Bett am linken Ende, dann ein Bett am rechten Ende, wieder eins in der Mitte und so weiter und so fort, also die hopfen da halt durch.
Aber das schon nach einem definierten Verfahren.
Genau, nach einem definierten Verfahren und es gibt da halt so einen Code, der halt bestimmt, welches Bit, also welches Rauschen, auf welcher Frequenz welches Bit bestimmt und die senden halt 20 mal so viele Bits, wie am Ende ankommt. Also es gibt halt sehr redundant, um halt die Störungen zu umgehen und das ist halt atmosphärischen Störungen unterworfen, das heißt, das kommt später an oder es ist verrauscht oder alle möglichen Dinge. So dann hast du halt das Problem, dass die Rechenleistung auf diesem Prozessor ist halt begrenzt und je genauer du rechnest, desto höher ist halt deine Anforderung an die Rechenleistung, weil du dann halt all möglichen Dinge dir noch angucken musst. Also kannst du dir noch die Phasenlage des Signals angucken, um es genauer zu kriegen und so. Dann gibt es zum Beispiel halt so GPS-Empfänger für so Landvermesser, die stellen so ein Ding dahin und lassen es da eine Stunde stehen, wenn sie halt eine genaue Position brauchen und das besteht nur aus vier GPS-Empfängern in einem Meter Abstand, die halt alle messen und über eine gewisse Zeit und dann halt die ganzen Fehler rausmitteln über die Zeit. Also da kann man halt alle halt Tricks noch machen so, was aber so für so eine Autonavigation unerheblich ist, da braucht man halt nicht. So von diesem Code gibt es halt zwei, es gibt halt den zivilen und den militärischen und der militärische ist halt verschlüsselt, weil er halt genauer ist, also dass das Zeitsignal genauer drin, als es im zivilen Code drin ist. Das heißt also mit dem militärischen Code...
Das heißt die Zeit ist nur höher aufgelöst? Korrekt und dadurch kannst du halt eine genauere Position anhalten.
Also die militärischen Empfänger wären so zwischen ein und drei Metern wohl angegeben.
Ich meine die Zeitauflösung, also was ist bei einem normalen Signal die Zeitauflösung? Keine Ahnung, okay.
Also irgendwelche Picosekunden oder...
Okay, aber daraus ergibt sich zwangsläufig die Genauigkeit, mit der man die Positionen bestimmen kann.
Genau, deswegen sind es halt auch Atomuhren, damit da halt kein Drift drin ist. Und die zweite Parameter, die man halt auch relativ genau braucht, ist halt die umlaufbare Satelliten, damit du halt weißt, wo, also wie weit der weg sich dann befindet, ist sozusagen die andere Richtung deiner Berechnung. Das heißt also innerhalb des GPS-Signals gibt es halt noch eine Übertragung, nicht nur das Zeitsignal, sondern auch der Umlaufbahn der Satelliten, in denen halt übertragen wird, welcher Satellit sich gerade wo, auf welchem Orbit befindet, ob dieser Orbit sich verändert hat oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und dieses militärische Signal ist halt genauer und ist halt noch redundanter, sodass es halt auch noch weniger fehleranfällig ist, also es wird auch mit einer höheren Datenrate gesendet und ist halt nicht bekannt, also die ist halt nicht öffentlich und dadurch, dass man nicht weiß, wann welches Bit wo gesendet wird, ist es de facto verschlüsselt. Dieser Schlüssel ist halt sehr lang, da wiederholt sich halt pro Satellit alle Woche. So also einmal pro Woche ist sozusagen der Schlüssel einmal rum. Das heißt also man sitzt da schon eine ganze Weile, weil er mal net dekodieren möchte.
Das haben sie dann halt in die Maflo-Körper eingebaut und ja und dann das heißt also militärisch kommen die dann auf zwei drei Meter genauigkeit ungefähr genauer ist halt so die so und der haben sie da meinst du, dass sie da jetzt auch schon ganz andere Algorithmen da einsetzen oder ist es im Prinzip genau die gleiche?
Na momentan ist es noch dieselbe Geschichte. Sie machen jetzt Upgrades da rein, dass sie halt mit stärkerer Sendenlastung sind in den neuen Satelliten, um halt störungsunabhängiger, also weniger störungsanfällig zu sein und sie rechnen da halt alle möglichen Dinge, um halt gegen Störungen sich zu sichern. Also gab es ja im Irak-Krieg diese Geschichten, dass die Irakis offenbar GPS-Störsender verwendet haben, um halt die amerikanischen Maflo-Körper abzulenken und dagegen halt immun zu werden, das ist halt Ziel von vielen Entwicklungen.
Das hältst du für wahrscheinlich, dass das stattgefunden hat?
Ja, also da gibt es auch in der öffentlichen Literatur ziemlich viel Diskussionen über diese ganzen Jamming-Geschichten, also Störungen von GPS und diese ganzen Dinge. Was aber für den zivilen Bereich halt interessant ist, ist halt die Abschaltung von diesem Selective Availability, also diese Einführung von künstlichen Fehlern, die halt von der Militär gefordert wurde. Die hat Clinton tatsächlich noch so als eine seiner wenigen positiven Amtshandlungen durchgesetzt gegen relativ starken Widerstand des Militärs. Und zwar, so weit ich mich erinnere, im Mai 2000. Und ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich gerade irgendwie einen Tag später auf einer Radtour war und mein GPS auspackte und tatsächlich war ich dann auf der Straße auf dem GPS und nicht irgendwo 150 Meter weiter im Gebüsch. Also sozusagen auf dem Display hat man immer gesehen, wo man eigentlich ist.
Warst du da noch, wann das war?
Das war Mai 2000.
Mai 2000.
Und danach ging es dann halt richtig los. Danach fing GPS halt so richtig an. Danach gab es halt Autonavigationssysteme, die wirklich das Auto auf der Straße hatten und nicht nur so ungefähr in der Gegend. Und dann fing diese ganzen, also praktisch die gesamte GPS-Industrie fing halt dann tatsächlich im Jahr 2000 richtig an.
So klingt die neue Windows Vista Fehlermeldung. Da muss man sich nicht groß umgewöhnen und im Radio Fritz.
Ich glaube, die hatten schonmal so ein ähnliches Ding.
Den meinst du?
Verstehe. Verstehe sie?
Auf busy kleines ist sehr schön.
Sven Trägt schon einer von den ganz großen.
Ja, ich denke auch irgendwie. Da sag ich doch nur...
Äh, machen wir ein bisschen weiter.
Warte mal, ich lass mal sagen, wie die Sendung ist, damit das so ein bisschen dieser bleibt. Ich erde das jetzt mal an dieser Stelle. Das ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Am letzten Mittwoch im Monat gibt es das Chaosradio. Heute Folge 116. Ortungssysteme mit Frank und Tim und Holgi.
Mit Holgi. Frank hat jetzt super mal ein bisschen technischen Einblick gegeben. Was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde, wir haben ja auch eine ganze Menge Fragen bekommen. Die haben auch alle versucht hier einzuarbeiten auf wiki.chaosradio.ch, auf der Vorbereitungsseite, die wir immer so bereithalten. Das ist alles sehr hilfreich. Es scheint so ein klassisches Missverständnis zu geben bei manchen Leuten. Dass es nämlich bei GPS so ist, dass man da einen Sender mit sich herum trägt. Das ist natürlich quark. Es gibt ausschließlich GPS-Empfänger. Diese empfänger werten schlicht die Signale aus, die die Satelliten die ganze Zeit aussenden. Es ist nicht so, dass da ein Dialog ist, dass man da irgendwas hinschickt und wieder was zurückbekommt.
So ein GPS-Empfänger ist praktisch wie ein Radioempfänger. Das ist technisch gesehen nicht viel anders. Das heißt, das Signal vom Satelliten, der Satellit sendet und der Empfänger empfängt. Und per se sendet der Empfänger erstmal gar nichts. Man kann wiederum den Empfänger mit einem Sender kombinieren, wenn man die Position anders hin übertragen möchte, so einen Trecker zu bauen. Aber da kommen wir später nochmal zu, aber so ein normaler GPS-Empfänger empfängt erstmal nur, oder es sendet sozusagen nichts, also nur um dieses Missverständnis mal aufzuklären.
Genau, aber es gibt jetzt noch einige neue Entwicklungen, um die Ortungsgenauigkeit von GPS zu erhöhen. Das hat so ein bisschen seinen Anfang genommen, vor allem im Flugbereich. Ich kenne ja jetzt nur die Geschichte von diesem Flughafen in der Schweiz, der so eng zwischen den Bergen liegt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, welcher das war, hast du da irgendwas in Erinnerung? Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall konnten sie dort eben eine bestimmte Größe an Flugzeugen nicht landen lassen, weil es schlicht zu gefährlich gewesen wäre, diese großen Flugzeuge da durch diese Talschneise fliegen zu lassen, weil sie einfach nicht genug Assistenz bekommen würden vom Computer, weil er eben die Position nicht genau genug bestimmen kann. Und das war quasi auch die Grundlage eines Systems, was man heute unter dem Namen DGPS kennt. Differential GPS basiert darauf, dass man zusätzlich zu den Signalen, die man von dem Satelliten erhält, noch ein stationäres Signal von einem, also ein Signal von einem stationären Punkt, von einem festen Punkt, in dem Fall war es halt der Flughafen selbst, bekommt, der quasi seine Position wie ein Satellit auch noch mit dazu nimmt. Und dadurch, dass man eben dessen Position wirklich auch noch genau kennt, verbessert das die mathematische Qualität bei der Auswertung, soweit man die Position...
Das ist nicht ganz korrekt.
Okay, dann korrigier mich mal. So, ich verstand.
Kein Satelliten simuliert, oder?
Nee, es simuliert keinen Satelliten. Was da passiert ist...
Okay, das war falsch formuliert, aber es ist ein Signal, was dazu kommt. So wie der...
Nee, nee, man kann es sogar präziser beschreiben.
Okay, komm mal los.
Und zwar der DGPS-Empfänger, also der halt am Flughafen zum Beispiel sitzt, enthält halt auch eigene GPS-Empfänger. Also der empfängt halt das GPS-Signal, wie es da in der Gegend ist. Und misst den Fehler für jeden einzelnen Satelliten, der in dieser Gegend zu sehen ist, und überträgt ein Korrektursignal. Das heißt, er sagt, er ist halt sozusagen... Der weiß sozusagen, der ist nur einen Kilometer von dem Flugzeug entfernt. Das heißt, er sieht eigentlich dieselben GPS-Satelliten. Und kann sehen, was jetzt gerade für ein Jitter ist, durch die atmosphärischen Störungen usw. und so weiter und so fort, da kann man davon ausgehen, dass die in einer Region grob dieselben sind. Wenn der Satellit eine Klatsche hat z.B. und die Uhr da so ein bisschen falsch geht, dann weicht halt die Position ab. Und er kennt halt seine eigene Position und sendet sozusagen die Differenz zu dem gemessenen Signal. Das heißt, der Misthaltet-GPS zeigt an, ich bin gerade 25 Meter weiter links von seiner Position, die er weiß. Also sendet er einen Offset von 25 Meter weiter links. Und im Flugzeug der GPS-Empfänger rechnet diesen Fehler, also sozusagen diese Fehlerkorrektur, diese Differenz auf das gemessene Signal von den GPS-Satelliten drauf. So funktioniert das. Und da gibt es halt noch...
Und wie viel genauer wird es dann?
Das geht runter bis zum Meter. Also mit DGPS wird man halt wirklich verflugt genau. Das hängt davon ab, wie groß die Entfernung zwischen dem Differential, der Differential-Station und dem GPS-Empfänger ist. Es gibt halt davon auch noch sozusagen die Industrial Scale Versionen, die halt irgendwie ganze Kontinente abdeckt. Das heißt dann VAS, das Wide Area Augmentation System. Da gibt es halt auch auf dem Boden halt so eine Messstation, die halt das GPS-Signal überwacht und einen Fehler ausrechnet. Und dieses Signal wird dann aber nicht über einen Funksender nur lokal verbreitet, sondern über einen geostationären Satelliten. Das heißt, es wird halt wie Satellitenfernsehen gesendet. Und der GPS-Empfänger kann dann sagen, okay, ich bin in der Region. Welche Differential-Station gibt es hier aus der Ausstrahlung von dem Satelliten? Und diesen Fehler wiederum korrigieren. Und damit kann man halt sozusagen diese Differential-GPS für ganze Kontinente bauen. Das europäische System heißt EGNOS. Und es ist eigentlich momentan in den USA primär deployed. Aber da passiert halt eine ganze Menge in diesen Verbesserungssystemen.
Das heißt, ich brauche aber einen angepassten Empfänger.
Aber den hast du mittlerweile auch schon zum Beispiel von Garmin. So ein Autonavigations-Dinks-Kauf für 400 Dollar ist da schon so ein WAS-Empfänger drin. Also ist halt so ein DGPS-Empfänger. Also die meisten etwas teuren GPS-Empfänger sind auch alle DGPS-Empfänger auf den Standardfrequenzen und WAS-Empfänger auf den Standardfrequenzen.
Okay, aber ich kriege das Differenzsignal nicht direkt von dem Ort, wo es gebildet wird, sondern ich bekomme es indirekt auch über die Satelliten weitergeleicht.
Über einen anderen Satelliten, ein WAS-Satelliten. Also ist halt meistens einfach nur ein Träger auf einem Fernsehsatelliten, der halt ein bisschen Bumms sendet. Das ist halt also ein recht einfacher, primitive System, weil da müssen auch nicht viele Daten rüber. Und du hast halt einen hochwertigen Sprechspektromempfänger in diesem GPS ohnehin schon drin. Und wenn die Frequenz relativ nah an der GPS-Frequenz liegt, kannst du halt einfach die GPS-Antenne mit benutzen und halt dieses Signal auch noch mit empfangen.
Das heißt, diese 10 Meter-Genauigkeit von GPS, die wird jetzt allein durch solche mathematischen Verbesserungen, du hast ja auch gesagt, die Sendeleistung wird hochgesetzt bei GPS. Im Prinzip entwickelt sich ja GPS dann technisch doch signifikant weiter. Die Frage, braucht man dann noch ein Galileo?
Ja, Galileo ist halt das europäische GPS-Äquivalent, das halt seit vielen Jahren diskutiert und dann doch jetzt endlich gebaut wird. Es gibt halt mehrere Gründe, weswegen halt die EU gesagt hat, wir bauen jetzt Galileo. Einer ist sicherlich Unabhängigkeit von den USA. Also GPS wird von den Amerikanern betrieben, also de facto vom amerikanischen Militär. Und ohne jegliche Garantie, das heißt also die Amerikaner sagen halt, wir schalten es halt ab, wenn irgendjemand abschalten, was halt zu massiven Problemen führen würde. Also wenn wir jetzt mal nur mal so kurz drüber nachdenken, wo überall GPS mittlerweile drin ist.
Ja, aber gemacht haben sie das doch noch nicht, oder?
Sie haben es wohl nur regional gemacht in irgendwelchen Kriegsfällen, aber man will sich da sicherlich nicht so richtig drauf verlassen, sodass sie halt, dass man halt, abhängig vom amerikanischen Militär, mit großen Teilen seiner z.B. Transportwirtschaft, ist halt schon so ein bisschen blöd. Also wenn halt irgendwie GPS mal ausfällt, dann werden viele Schiffe einfach stillgelegt. Also die gehen dann halt vor Anker, da wo sie gerade sind.
Mehr oder weniger automatisch wahrscheinlich so.
Weil die werden halt von Leuten gefahren, die können halt kein Sechs-Tank mehr bedienen und Loran C haben die auch noch nie gehört. Und die bleiben halt einfach stehen, die warten halt, bis GPS wieder angemacht wird. Ist halt zu gefährlich, du kannst halt irgendwie... Also zum Beispiel so großen Öltankern, die haben halt mehrere GPS-Empfänger, vorne und hinten, damit sie auch die Position des Schiffs sozusagen messen können. Weil irgendwie so 200 Meter Abstand vorne bis hinten ist halt schon signifikant, dass sie benutzen tatsächlich auch die GPS-Empfänger für die Feinstauung des Schiffs, wenn sie halt in so einen Hafen reinfahren und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und wenn das halt weg ist, dann haben die halt ein richtiges Problem. Und das war halt einer der Gründe Galileo zu entwickeln, zu sagen, wir wollen halt ein zweites System haben, was halt nicht abhängig von den Amerikanern ist, was eine höhere Leistungsklasse aufweist, also wo halt auch der normale zivile Service schon ein bisschen Meter runtergeht, also Metergenauigkeit runtergeht. Und wo man halt auch einen militärischen Service hat, für das europäische Militär, der halt nicht von den Amerikanern angefasst werden kann und vor allen Dingen eine wesentlich höhere Verfügbarkeitsgarantie. Also Galileo sagt halt, wir wollen halt die Genauigkeit und die Verfügbarkeit von GPS-Bewaltigung übertreffen, so, dass wir damit Flugzeuge automatisch steuern können. Also einer der Ziele ist halt, zu sagen, wir gehen von diesen Luftkorridoren weg, dass Flugzeuge halt in so Korridoren fliegen, sondern lassen die halt lang fliegen, wo sie wollen. Wir bauen halt so ein großes System, dass die alle ihre Positionen broadcasten und sich dann irgendwie selber zurechtfinden, dass sie nicht zusammenstoßen.
Also das ist ja nur, das ist Pflichten.
Dafür möchten sie halt einfach gerne zwei unabhängige Systeme haben. Es gibt halt noch tausend andere Gründe, die viel mit europäischer Industrieförderung zu tun haben und Tax Money Recycling und all diesen Dingen. Und der europäischen Luft- und Raumfahrtindustrie, die immer wieder ein Prestigeprojekt brauchte. Und geostrategische Gründe, dass die Russen, Chinesen und Inder auch gerne mitmachen wollten und das auch mitmachen.
Aber die Russen haben doch ihr eigenes System, oder?
Die haben GLONASS, ja. GLONASS ist halt auch ein russisches Militärsystem, was halt sozusagen mit Äquivalenz zu GPS ist. Hat so im Best Case so was wie 60 Meter Genauigkeit, also ist halt nicht so richtig toll. Und hat halt den großen Nachteil, dass die Empfänger halt nicht so richtig klein zu kriegen sind momentan. Die typischen Empfänger sind halt so Einbaugeräte in irgendwelche interkontinentale Raketen, Marschle-Körper, Motorjachten oder was auch immer man damit halt so steuern möchte.
Nicht diese kleinen süßen Motoresteile und so.
Das Problem ist halt, dass die Russen verlieren die Satelliten. Momentan haben sie glaube ich so was wie 90% Verfügbarkeit. Und dann haben sie halt auch das Problem, dass die, momentan haben sie glaube ich nur 12 Satelliten oder 13 Satelliten von irgendwie 20 oder so, die sie eigentlich brauchen. Also es ist halt schon so ein bisschen ein Rottensystem.
Das heißt, sie steigen jetzt einfach bei Galileo mit ein und sind froh, dass sie zumindest dann ein bisschen die Alternative haben.
Naja, die werden, also die Russen werden Glonass schon noch weiter betreiben, weil es halt ihr Militärsystem ist. Also das ist halt das System, was halt ihr Militär braucht. Aber das Ziel ist halt schon, dass sie halt auch ein ziviles System da eine Beteiligung dran haben wollen, halt an Galileo. Also es gibt halt noch ein, wenn wir schon bei den Choreositäten sind, gibt es halt auch noch ein chinesisches System. Das heißt Baidu. Und es deckt halt irgendwie nur China ab, soweit ich verstanden habe. Was halt, naja, sozusagen ihre Nachbarschaft ist. Also sie wollte halt sozusagen nur so ein Domestik und nähere Expansionsgegend. Da haben sie dann halt ihr eigenes Navigationssystem. Ja, aber auch die Chinesen machen halt bei Galileo mit, weil sie halt billige Galileo-Empfänger bauen wollen, glaube ich. Also so was wir heute so kriegen, die GPS-Empfänger, die kleinen sind ja auch irgendwie alle mit in China. Genau, hier hat er gerade so einen kleinen von mir.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Bluetooth-GPS-Empfänger, den kannst du mit deinem Mobiltelefon kombinieren. So eine kleine Kisse.
Oder auch mit deinem Laptop, das ist halt Bluetooth.
Gerade in der Hand, das ist halt so ein bisschen größer als eine Streichel-Schachtel enthält, hat ein Akku und hat halt einen 32-Kanal-Empfänger, also der halt wirklich richtig doll schnell ist. Wie heißt das Gerät?
Das heißt Ho Chi Minh Flower Power Enterprises. Das baut mittlerweile fast jeder Taiwan-Hersteller.
Super Deluxe 3 oder so. Also halt, keine Ahnung, 50 Euro von Ebay.
Aber das funktioniert?
Ja, funktioniert super.
Die basieren alle auf diesem gleichen Chip Surf, SIFR 3. Das ist so die letzte Entwicklung. Das sind halt die, die jetzt einfach alle Satelliten mitrechnen. Von daher extrem schnell wieder in der Resynchronisierung sind. Also das haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen. So ein typisches Problem bei GPS ist, dadurch, dass die Signale relativ sanft daherkommen, sind natürlich alle Dinge, die so rumstehen, schon mal ein Problem. Also Bäume, Häuser im Besonderen, weil man da eben noch zusätzlich starke Reflexionen hat durch die nackten Wände. Und jeder, der schon mal mit GPS gearbeitet hat, weiß, rein in den Tunnel und das Signal ist halt weg. Und ein großes Problem bei den frühen Empfängern war, dass die sich eben nicht so schnell wieder hineinsinkronisiert haben. Die haben halt erstmal keine Satelliten mehr gesehen und haben erstmal Panik geschrien. Danach haben sie wieder Sicht, wenn man aus dem Tunnel rauskommt und dann fangen sie wieder von vorne an zu berechnen, wo bin ich denn überhaupt, was sind denn das überhaupt für Satelliten, wo fliegen die hin. Während halt die modernen Chips im Prinzip in der Zwischenzeit einfach alles mitrechnen und in dem Moment, wo sie ein oder ein paar Satelliten halt wieder sehen, sofort wissen, alles klar, das kann jetzt eigentlich nur diese Position sein auf Basis dessen, was halt vorher war. Und das ist mittlerweile eben so Mainstream, dass man das eben für wenig Geld reinbauen kann. Also das Ding enthält so ein Standard Nokia Telefon-Akku. Das heißt, den kann man auch mit jedem normalen Telefon aufladen. Das haben also noch nicht mal die Kosten eines speziellen Akkus. Da nimmt man halt einfach Nokia, weil das ist für die Stromversorgung im Prinzip dasselbe. Das ist ein kleines Stecker, wo du noch eine Antenne reinstecken kannst. Vorne ein Button zum Einschalten und Ausschalten. Und der Rest geht eben über Bluetooth. Das kannst du einfach per einfachen Pairing mit deinem Computer einfach verbinden. Und dann erscheint das so wie eine serielle Schnittstelle. Und man kann einfach ein Programm da dran werfen. Und es liest dann konsequent einen Datensatz nach dem anderen. Da gibt es dann auch ein standardisiertes Datensatzformat. Das nennt sich NMEA. NMEA steht für Naval, das ist halt so eine Organisation, die sich um die Standardisierung im Marinebereich kümmert. Weil das ja im Prinzip die Hauptanwendung war Schifffahrt zunächst einmal. Die haben im Prinzip die ganzen Standards gesetzt. Das spucken heutzutage alle Geräte aus. Also alle sprechen dieses NMEA-Format. Und damit kann man das eben auch in alle GPS-fressenden Programme mühelos randocken.
Also der Standard heißt eben immer nur NMEA 0183. NMEA steht für National Marine Electronics Association. Das heißt eine amerikanische Organisation. Und dieser Standard 183 beschreibt genau dieses Datenformat, was aus praktisch allen GPSen so rauskommt. Und was auch eigentlich fast alle Programme, die irgendwie Geopositionen verarbeiten, verstehen mittlerweile.
Wobei man schon sagen muss, das ist halt so ein generisches Rekordformat. Und jeder Gerät schmeißt dann nochmal eine andere Information raus. Also es gibt da so verschiedene Sentences, die da definiert sind. Und es gibt so drei oder vier, die Positionen enthalten. Und andere Sentences erzählen dir irgendwas, über welche Satelliten gerade sichtbar sind. Also man kann sich da alles Mögliche rausziehen. Und man muss eben mehr als einen Rekordtyp da unterstützen, wenn man wirklich umfangreiche Informationen haben will. Aber wenn es einem wirklich jetzt nur darum geht, XY und im Zweifelsfall auch noch Z auszuwerten, ist das relativ einfach. Ich habe letzte Woche da mal ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und das einfach mal an meinen Rechner gekoppelt und dann hintenrum die aktuelle Position dann in Google Earth visualisierbar gemacht. Das ist kein besonderer Aufwand, den man da treiben muss. Und so kann man eben sehr schön Realtime-Tracking machen. Was sicherlich eine der tollen Anwendungen ist, die man heutzutage gerne ausprobieren möchte. Eine der? Eine der. Da gibt es ja doch eine ganze Menge. Ja, das wäre natürlich mal ein interessanter Ausblick, was man dann eigentlich mit dem ganzen Kram machen kann. Was natürlich jeder kennt, ist Autonavigation. Fast jedes moderne Luxusauto und eigentlich auch schon die Mittelklasse verfügt heutzutage mindestens über eine Option eines Navigationssystems.
Und alle anderen kann man halt so einen kleinen Tom-Tom oder ähnliche Geräte einfach mit so einem Saugner reinflanschen.
Ich finde, das sieht irgendwie so doof aus, wenn dann die ganzen komischen Leute mit den billigen PDAs, die an die Windschutzscheibe gepfopft sind.
Voll der Trend, sag ich dir.
Ja, ich eile mich auch eigentlich nur darüber, dass ich nicht die Idee hatte, denen das zu verkaufen.
Genau, die waren auch schon lange vor dir da. Also der Marktführer in dem Bereich ist halt TomTom, das ist eine holländische Firma, die halt schon sehr lange so Navigationskram macht. Und irgendwann dann auf die Idee kam, irgendwie mit diesen PDAs in diesem nassen Gefrickel, dass sie das nicht entweder bauen, aber mal eine schöne billige chinesische Hardware drumherum. Um dieses Problem.
Auch ein interessantes Gerät, weil es auf Linux basiert. Wir haben das hier auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, in anderen Zusammenhängen, weil sie sich am Anfang ja da ein bisschen bei der Lizenz vertan haben. Also bei der Lizenz haben sie es nicht vertan, aber in einer Einhaltung der Lizenzbedingungen. Das führt ja dann eben zur Öffnung des Codes. Das heißt, es gibt heute eben auch die Software, die da drauf läuft als Open Source. Weitgehend natürlich nicht die Daten, aber man kann da auf jeden Fall dran rumhackern.
Ja, also die funktionieren mittlerweile einigermaßen gut. Also es gibt da halt durchaus, sagen wir mal, eine recht ausgereifte Benutzerführung mittlerweile. Also man kann auch so der etwas einfache, gestrickte Autofahrer verstehen. Lustig sind immer die Warnungen.
Was ich nicht in Seltsam finde, ist, dass die Dinge aber nicht billiger zu werden scheinen. Also ich habe das Gefühl, als würde ich...
Naja, es gibt halt schon so einen Markt für so China-Billigprodukte, die halt auch dann, naja, wo man dann den Preiswertaspekt halt schon deutlich merkt. Aber die, wie sagen wir mal, momentan zahlen die Leute halt noch die 400 Euro für die Dinge. Und dann kann man es halt auch kassieren, so.
Na, ich denke der Preis wird ja nicht nur durch Hard- und Software, sondern vor allem durch die Daten bestimmt. Was kostet denn das so? Also wo kriegt man überhaupt solche Daten her?
Na, die Daten ist ein sehr schönes Monopol, die Enduro-Pro genau gesagt. Also es gibt halt zwei Firmen, die halt für den europäischen und amerikanischen Markt sich diese Datenauslieferung teilen. Die eine Firma ist Naftech, die andere heißt Teleatlas. Teleatlas ist eine holländische Firma, Naftech kommt aus den USA. Daraus folgt wiederum, so dass immer jeweils die Datensätze für Europa bzw. Amerika immer ein bisschen schlechter sind auf der anderen Seite. Was die halt tun, ist, die vermessen halt wirklich die Straßen. Das heißt, die arbeiten halt auf Basiskarten und dann schicken sie aber auch tatsächlich Fahrzeuge mit GPS-Empfängern durch die Gegend, um halt zum Beispiel neue Straßen aufzunehmen, um halt Einbahnstraßen festzustellen und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt halt durchaus bizarre Probleme, die man da sorgt, also es gibt zum Beispiel Städte in Italien, die haben halt fast nur Einbahnstraßen in der Innenstadt. Und damit sich niemand langweilt, flippen die halt alle halbe Jahre die Einbahnstraßenrichtung. Also die invertieren sozusagen im gesamten Einbahnstraßensystem und mit der Begründung, dass man den Verkehr halt so ein bisschen mehr über die Stadt verteilt und dann sich nicht so die Schwerpunkte bilden. Das ist natürlich in so einem Datensatz so ein bisschen tricky abzubilden. Also weil normalerweise hast du in so einem Datensatz steht halt drin irgendwie Straße, ist halt irgendwie da und da und da und lang und hat diesen und jenen Namen und das ist halt eine Einbahnstraße. Aber dass halt da eine zeitbasierte Invertierung ran muss von dieser Einbahnstraße, ist natürlich nicht für ihn so einfach abzubilden. Jedenfalls, die haben lustige Probleme, diese Datenlieferanten. Die sind sozusagen ganz unten in der Nahrungskette. Dann kommen halt die Hersteller von den Softwarekomponenten für diese Navigationsgeräte und halt die Hardwarehersteller, die den ganzen Kram dann zusammenbauen. Da wird ganz gut Geld verdient in diesem Markt. Das haben noch nicht alle Autos Navigationssysteme. Da kann man halt noch irgendwie weiterverkaufen.
In Hamburg gibt es übrigens auch so eine Straße, die sich immer umdreht. Direkt an der Alza. Die ist morgens in die eine Richtung und dann in die andere Richtung.
Ja, morgens und abends geht die nachher alle halbe Jahre. Das ist wirklich fies.
Das ist immer angenehmer.
Mein Gott, wir haben den Axel verhungern lassen. Echt? Oh Gott. Der ist jetzt nicht der Dünnste.
Der hatte noch einen zweiten Beitrag.
Der hatte noch einen zweiten Beitrag, Axel. Entschuldige.
Ist schon fast ein bisschen spät, macht aber nichts.
Haben wir schon wieder was falsch gemacht?
Nein, ich hab nicht immer die Telefonanlage im Hintergrund.
Sie mich das Primäre, weshalb die Satelliten ihre Lebensdauer begrenzt haben, liegt daran, dass die ja relativ niedrig fliegen. Die sind ja maximal 150, 200 Kilometer hoch. Das heißt, sie fliegen noch in einem Bereich, wo die Erdatmosphäre bremsend wirkt. Das heißt, die fallen immer weiter runter. Sie brauchen Lageregelungstriebwerke, um wieder auf ihre ursprüngliche Bahn zurückzukommen. Und irgendwann ist einfach der Treibstofffaller. Man hat mittlerweile mal versucht, die sozusagen einzufangen mit dem Space Shuttle, wieder aufzutanken. Ja, es geht wohl, ist aber auch nicht gerade preiswert.
Vor allem, wenn sie nicht sicherstellen können, dass sie auch rechtzeitig einen Space Shuttle hochkriegen.
Ja, genau, mittlerweile ist ja auch das Problem. Die GPS-Satelliten fliegen halt sehr hoch, die fliegen halt bei 20.000 Kilometern. Also die haben noch nicht so richtig das Problem, dass sie wirklich von der Atmosphäre in dem Haus abgewandt sind. Aber halten sie trotzdem.
Das ist tatsächlich eins der Probleme. Das nächste ist, was spannend ist, die Uhren, die da drin sind, gehen langsamer. Wenn man diese Atomuhr auf der Erde betreiben wollen, würde die Zeit langsamer gehen. Weil dank der einsteinischen Relativitätstheorie sind die außerhalb des Gravitationsfeldes der Erde. Die Techniker haben das anfänglich nicht geglaubt, dass die Physiker ihnen das vorgerechnet haben. In den ersten Satelliten waren zwei Zeitgeber drin. Einer wirklich mit der Taktrate, die 9, 8 Gigahertz, die auf der Erde üblich sind. Und einer mit der vorausberechneten Frequenz, was die Physiker für diese Höhe ausgerechnet haben. Man musste mit den Sätzen feststellen, die vorausberechnete stimmt.
Was ist denn dein Hintergrund? Bist du auch Physiker? Und hast du jetzt ein spezielles Interesse in diesem Gebiet? Du hast gesagt, Messtechnik, was machst du denn dann?
Ich hab mal bei dem deutschen Maßgeber gearbeitet, bei der PTP. Allerdings nicht bei den Zeitmessleuten, aber ich hab halt bei der PTP mal gearbeitet.
Also der Physikalisch-Technischen Bundesanstalt?
Bei der Physikalisch-Technischen Bundesanstalt, die sozusagen für Deutschland festlegt, was ist Meter, Sekunde, Kilogramm und so weiter.
Ah ja.
Ja, so viel nur noch ganz kurz dazu. Ansonsten, ja... Persönlich anmerksam. Übrigens, dieser NMEA 0183 Schipstanze, was GPS dort liefert, ist bloß eine ganz kleine Untermenge, dieses kompletten Befehlssatz. Der kann auch alles Mögliche anrufen. Der kann auch irgendwie Messsysteme von Echolot und Messsysteme von Loran kann der tatsächlich auch noch. Und Lok und sowas. Und der GPS-Zeichensatz sind bloß 7 oder 8 Befehle, glaube ich. Ich habe das irgendwie mal auseinandersortiert.
Das sind ein paar mehr, so 20, aber stimmt schon.
Ja, schlammig tut es, ich weiß es nicht mehr. Irgendwie 3 Jahre her, oder so, was ich schon gemacht habe. Das ist gar nicht viel, was da rauskommt. Und wie gesagt, aber der Zeichensatz umfasst wesentlich mehr. Das ist irgendwie so ein 3-Letter-Code, der sagt, was da an Informationen dahinter kommt und daraus folgend erklärt sich dann, wie das dahinter aussieht. Das ist ASCII Lesbo, das ist relativ einfach. Eine nette Spielerei.
Vielen Dank für den Hinweis. Sag mal Frank, hier mit den Karten. Also was du ja vorhin gesagt hast hier mit Tele Atlas und wie war der andere Name? Navtech? Navtech. Die liefern aber nur Karten, also Straßenkarten. Wo gehen die durch diese Straße und Wege lang?
Da gibt es halt noch natürlich diese ganze Untermenge, dieser besonderen Points of Interest. Also wo sind halt irgendwie Tankstellen, Hotels und diese ganzen Dinge? Da gibt es noch so ganze Submarkte, die sich darum kümmern. Dann natürlich dieser ganze Bereich Verkehrsdaten. Also wo ist gerade Stau und wo sind die Baustellen und die ganzen Dinge, die halt auch nach und nach in diese Navigationssysteme einfließen. Also man versucht halt möglichst...
Also auch so richtige Realtime-Updates.
Genau, also man versucht halt über Mobiltelefonnetze oder über Radiosender halt die Updates in die Geräte zu bekommen, dass sie halt nicht in den Stau reinroten. Das ist so die nächste Entwicklungsschwelle, die jetzt gerade so läuft, dass die Dinge halt auch wirklich in den Stau umfahren können. Bei den auto-eingebauten Systemen gibt es halt schon eine ganze Weile, die sind aber auch immer noch sehr teuer. Und jetzt ist halt die nächste Welle halt in diese kleinen Geräte beziehungsweise in die PDA-basierten Systeme reinzubringen. Also man kann ja auch mit zum PDA navigieren, wenn man halt so einen kleinen GPS daran steckt. Roy, wie ich gesagt habe, er hat irgendwie noch einen Schublade liegen, der irgendwie rumgammelt. Da kaufst du dir halt eine Software für und kannst sie dann mit so einem Bluetooth-GPS halt zum Navigieren benutzen. Das ist halt ein bisschen ein Getrödel, weil da irgendwie Kabel und Strom und Akku alle und so. Aber man kann es halt wesentlich benutzen. Man kommt über den Urlaub damit.
Okay, wir reden die ganze Zeit über Autos, die dann richtig auf der Straße fahren. Aber es gibt doch noch mehr hübsche Sachen, die man mit Navigation machen kann.
Ja, ich mein, es tut sich natürlich jetzt eine ganze Menge in diesem Geomarkt. Wollen wir auch noch ein bisschen mehr darauf eingehen. Ich glaube, das sichtbarste Projekt der letzten Zeit sind diese ganzen online Maps, die halt auch nicht nur Straßenkarten, sondern eben auch Satellitenbilder bringen. Also so online Maps gibt es ja schon lange. So Stadtplantdienst.de war so einer der allerersten, die überhaupt gestartet sind. Später kann ich jetzt nur runterrasseln, was jetzt hier in Berlin immer noch mit angeboten hat. Berliner Stadtplancom gab es da noch und Berlin Online hat auch noch einen. Also aber das waren halt alles so diese typischen Straßenkarten. Und jetzt seit kurzem gibt es eben auch diese gemischte Aufbereitung mit Luftbildern und mit Satellitenbildern, was lange Zeit noch so ein exklusiver Markt war. Das heißt, man bekam das nur, wenn man dann wieder mehr Geld bezahlt hat dafür, weil das natürlich auch einen echten Nutzen hat für eine ganze Menge Branchen. Also ich denke Veranstalter zum Beispiel, die Open-Air-Veranstaltungen machen oder generell Bauplanungen, Raumplanungen, im weiteren Sinne Verkehrsplanungen, Stadtplanungen. Das sind natürlich solche Systeme wirklich super. Insbesondere, wenn sie eben schön interaktiv sind und man da eben mehr machen kann, als nur draufgucken, wenn man sich irgendwie Flächen ausrechnen lassen kann, Distanzen. Google hat dann einen großen Schritt gemacht, indem sie Google Maps angeboten haben. Wie lange ist das jetzt eigentlich her? Auch schon eineinhalb, zwei Jahre. Und vor allem natürlich auch deshalb, weil sie mal wieder ein sehr viel besseres User-Interface dazu geknallt haben, also so ganz einfache Sachen, wie dass man das nehmen kann und von links nach rechts dragen kann. Die anderen Sachen waren halt immer noch so total Web 1.0-mäßig.
Na gut, sie hatten halt Glück, dass gerade richtige JavaScript in allen Browser ankam.
Sie wissen ja auch schon, wann sie mit so was kommen können. Und dann haben sie es halt auch sehr schnell und sehr gut angegangen. Jetzt sind die anderen so ein bisschen in das Hintertreffen gekommen, zumindest hat man den Eindruck. Yahoo! Maps geht jetzt glaube ich immer noch auf Flash. Mal gucken, wie lange sie dabei noch bleiben. Ich glaube ja nicht, dass das besonders erfolgreich ist. Aber die eigentliche Arbeit war ja hinter den Kulissen. Und das bedeutete nämlich, Google sammelt halt Daten über die Welt. Und das Hauptinteresse ist natürlich Werbung anzuzeigen. Und dann kam halt gleich noch das andere Flagship-Programm hinterher, Google Earth. Was natürlich extrem suchtbildend ist.
Also interessant ist ja, dass Google Earth gab es ja sozusagen schon weit vorher diese Idee.
Gab es schon vor zehn Jahren.
Also da braucht man eigentlich noch etwas größer Computer dafür.
Genau, Google Earth ist nämlich eigentlich eine Erfindung aus Berlin. Das müssen wir hier fairerweise mal sagen. Ja, sprich gibt es nämlich eine Firma, die heißt artplus.com, die hatte ein Projekt, das war damals noch so ein Telekom-Forschungsprojekt. Das hieß Terravision und das wurde auch viel auf Messen gezeigt und hat im Prinzip genau die selbe Idee gehabt wie Google Earth. Also eine Realtime-Projektion, auf so eine richtige Kugel auf dem Computer, wo man eben interaktiv beliebig an irgendwelche Stellen hineinfliegen kann. Und während man eben runterfliegt, verfeinert sich eben die Auflösung, solange eben Daten dort noch verfügbar waren. Und dann eben auch diese Idee mit den Layern, die man da oben drauf einblenden kann, dass man also solche Place Marks hat, dass man auch 3D-Modelle noch integrieren kann. In gewisser Hinsicht ging das Ding sogar noch viel weiter, aber man konnte auch in die Häuser reinfliegen und man konnte auch mal komplett die Gravitation ausschalten und dann hatte man irgendwie keine runde Erde, sondern irgendwie so einen komischen unförmigen Gnubbel, der...
Was ist da draus geworden?
Na ja, das ist halt ein System gewesen, was nicht unbedingt für PCs geschrieben wurde. Das System als solches gibt es nach wie vor.
Also man brauchte halt irgendwie so ein 1-Million-Mark-Computer dafür.
Oder aber heutzutage ist das ja...
Ja, ein bisschen schade. Es gab dann halt eine Firma namens Keyhole, die praktisch ein ähnliche System für PCs entwickelt hatten. Die wurde dann halt von Google gekauft und daraus wurde...
Die haben das halt geklont.
Da wurde dann halt Google erst draus. Ab dem Kommen hatte halt einfach andere Dinge zu tun, glaube ich. Also der ist halt manchmal so wieder zu weit vorne vor der Zeit und dann ist halt nichts geworden. Die Idee dahinter aber zu sagen, wir haben halt eine komplette Abbildung des Planeten in so einem planetenförmigen virtuellen Objekt, hat ja auch noch in der Science-Fiction-Literatur starke Würdigung erfahren, im Snowcrash gibt es ja dieses, wie das Buch bekannt ist von Neil Stevenson, gibt es ja dieses schöne Programm Earth. Wo dann halt die Satellitenbilder halt schon live drin sind. Also ein bisschen Zeit geht dann auch ins Land, aber mittlerweile ist halt so, dass Google halt offensichtlich von allen großen Satellitenbildanbietern aktuelle Satellitenbilder oder relativ aktuelle Satellitenbilder bulk aufkauft und die dann halt nach und nach in die Google-Erde integriert. Und da kommen wir der Sache schon näher. Also je höher die Update-Frequenz bei den Satellitenbild-Anbietern wird, desto höher wird ihr dann wahrscheinlich auch bei Google werden.
Soweit wissen wir, was Google macht mit diesen ganzen Navigationssachen. Was ihr damit macht, würde uns auch interessieren. Nach den Nachrichten würden wir ganz gerne mit euch telefonieren.
Genau, wenn ihr coole Projekte macht mit GPS oder mit Tracking live oder auch nicht live, wenn ihr ein GPS in irgendeiner Form anders ganz gerne was darüber hören. Dann könnt ihr anrufen.
0331 70 97 110, aber erst nach den Nachrichten der Mario. Der macht nämlich sowohl die Nachrichten als auch das Telefon.
Der Mario macht das Telefon!
Es folgt eine wichtige Produktinformation zum Hören und Sehen von Fritz. In den folgenden 40 Sekunden erfahrt ihr, dass Fritz ab dem 1. September anders aussieht, dass euch Fritz weiter täglich mit Musik, Spaß und Informationen versorgt und wie ihr bei all dem auch noch was gewinnen könnt. Und los geht's!
Ab dem 1. September sieht Fritz anders aus. Findet heraus wie und besorgt euch die aktuelle Fritz Gewinnspielkarte. In Clubs, Bars und Kneipen in Berlin und Brandenburg und bei Fritz. Gewinnt mit der Karte ein MP3-Player mit Radio oder ein nagelneues Fritz-Shirt. Achso und ansonsten gibt euch Fritz weiterhin rund um die Uhr Information und Spaß und Musik und im Radio.
Fritz vom RBB 1,512.
Fritz Info Nachrichten mit Mario Bartsch Im Atomstreit mit dem Iran wollen die USA so rasch wie möglich über Sanktionen diskutieren, falls die Führung in Teheran nicht doch noch in letzter Minute einlenken sollte. Ausnahmsprecher McCormick sagte in Washington, bereits die erste Resolution müsse ein beachtliches Signal an den Iran senden, dass es sich um eine ernsthafte Sache handle. Danach müsse der Druck auf die Führung in Teheran Schritt für Schritt erhöht werden. Energieexperten rechnen nach der jüngsten Entscheidung der Bundesnetzagentur nicht mit deutlich sinkenden Strom- und Gaspreisen. Im besten Fall werde es eine sehr geringe Entlastung geben, sagte ein Sprecher des Bundes der Energieverbraucher. Die deutschen Stadtwerke gehen sogar von weiter steigenden Strompreisen aus. Das Hamburger Unternehmen Carnegie will in der leerstehenden Chipfabrikhalle in Frankfurt oder Solartechnik produzieren. Mittelfristig könnten bis zu 1000 Arbeitsplätze entstehen, berichteten mehrere Zeitungen und der Berufung auf einen Unternehmenssprecher. Förderanträge für das Vorhaben seien bereits gestellt. Mehrere Billigfluganbieter haben die Planungen für den Großflughafen Berlin-Brandenburg international kritisiert. Neun Billigfluglinien drohten heute gemeinsam mit ihrem Rückzug aus Berlin. In einem Appell heißt es, die Planungen für den Flughafen seien nur auf die traditionellen und teuren Fluggesellschaften wie Lufthansa ausgerichtet. Andere internationale Flughäfen würden den Billigfliegern eigene abgetrennte Terminals zur Verfügung stellen. Dies sei in Berlin nicht der Fall. Heute Nacht soll es regnen, die Temperaturen sinken auf 13 bis 10 Grad. Am Tag wird es wolkig, aber auch mal heiter, bei Höchstwerten um 21 Grad. Mit keinen aktuellen Meldungen, überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, gleich vier Minuten, nachher 12.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Chaosradio 2016.
And see.
Uns alle gewohnt.
Da könnt ihr auch anrufen im Radio 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline. Wir wüssten ganz gerne von euch. Und was ihr so für coole Sachen macht mit euren GPS-Gerätschaften oder ähnlichem, was es da so alles gibt.
Oder seid ihr schon mal mit eurem Auto-Navigationssystem in einen Fluss gefallen oder seid ihr Geo-Casher?
Da hab ich mal meinen Bootsführerschein gemacht, wo dieser Idiot mit dem BMW, der hat auch einer seinen Siebener versenkt. Das war unten in der Nähe von Kaput. Da setzt du eine kleine Fähre über, die hört auf den Namen Tussi 2. Und das Ding hat dann damals in seinem dicken Auto irgendwie das als Straße dargestellt. Und er hat sich dann nicht darauf verlassen, dass da ein Schild stand, Achtung, hier Ufer, sondern hat sich gedacht, mein Navigationssystem sagt, da ist eine Straße, ist da mitten in der Nacht durchgerauscht.
Da war der Kaput, der BMW.
Und hat er den Navi-Hersteller verklagt?
Ja, das war Bosch. Also es ist jetzt auch nur, es ist lange her. Also ich meine, es wäre Bosch gewesen seinerzeit. Und Bosch hat einfach nur gesagt, ja, das ist eine Klageabweisung oder wie auch immer man das nennt, haben sie ihm in ihrer Stellungnahme geschrieben, wir bauen Navigationssysteme, keine Autopiloten. Das ist nicht die letzteste Antwort, die du geben kannst.
So, wo waren wir denn? Wir waren bei den Karten und bei den, was mich ja noch mal interessiert ist, also jetzt Google Earth besticht ja, also Google Earth hat ja überhaupt gar keine Straßenkarten. Also hat schon Straßen, aber es sieht nicht genauso aus wie bei Google Maps. Was ich jetzt ein bisschen, was natürlich im Wesentlichen hier reizvoll ist, dass man auf die reale Welt blickt. Das heißt, man hat im Wesentlichen Satellitenbilder, aber wohl auch Luftbilder, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das ist eine Kombination. Wo kriegt man die denn her?
Satellitenbilder gibt es mittlerweile drei oder vier kommerzielle Anbieter, die hochauflösende Satellitenbilder anbieten. Also man kann die da halt kaufen und die machen die mit ihren Satelliten. Es funktioniert in der Regel so, dass es so ein bisschen Tasken gibt. Das heißt, man geht zu diesem Anbieter und sagt, ich hätte gerne von dieser und jener Ecke der Welt halt mal ein schönes hochauflösendes Luftbild um mir halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie den Fortschritt beim Bau irakischer Atomreaktoren anzugucken oder was auch immer einem so einfällt. Dann steuern die halt ihren Satelliten, sodass sie halt ein hübsches Bild von der Gegend machen. Und dann gibt es halt verschiedene Methoden, wie es danach weitergeht. Entweder man hat dieses Bild exklusiv, dann wird es teuer, oder man hat es halt nur für einen Monat exklusiv. Und danach geht es halt in ein öffentliches Archiv von diesen Satellitenbild-Anbietern.
Wo es dann jeder kaufen kann für weniger Geld.
Genau, da kann man es dann für ein Zehntel des Originalpreises in der Regel so kaufen. Und dann hat Google offensichtlich mit den Satellitenbild-Anbietern so einen Rahmenvertrag gemacht, dass sie halt einfach die kompletten Archive kriegen. Das glaubst du oder das weißt du? Ich glaube es, weil anders kann man sich diese Mengen von Bilderdaten, die sie da haben, nicht erklären. Und man sieht ja halt auch immer, wenn man in Google aus rumfliegt, sieht man immer diese kleinen Einblendungen unten. Copyright-Terror sowieso, Space hast du nicht gesehen, so diese ganzen Reseller von diesen Satellitenbild-Daten. Genau, das sind halt die Reseller, also nicht die Leute, die tatsächlich die Satelliten betreiben, sondern halt die Reseller, die diese Daten weiter vertreiben. Das ist halt ein recht großes Business. Und Google Earth ist halt für die Leute natürlich schön, weil sie eine konstante Einkommensquelle haben. Also sie verkaufen jedes Bild zumindest zweimal in eigentlichen Kunden, zweitmal an Google. Und dadurch rechnet es sich natürlich sehr für die. Interessant ist halt, dadurch kann man auch mal sehen, wo halt Bilder geupdatet werden. Also zum Beispiel vor einem Jahr ungefähr gab es vom Iran halt nur sehr wenige hochaufgelöste Bilder. So, dann gab es und zwar waren die von Boucher, von dem einen Atomreaktor, und noch von so einer Ops-Cone-Installation, irgendwo in der Wüste und noch so von zwei, drei Stellen. Und dann ging es halt echt schnell. Also dann wurde halt irgendwie so die ganze Küste einmal abgegrast offensichtlich. Und naja, und auch so die anderen interessanten Stellen. Noch hübsches auch immer wieder so Taiwan und China. Also die Straße von Taiwan ist auf beiden Seiten so die bestfotografierte Gegend der Welt. Weil die halt sich gegenseitig, also ich weiß nicht, ob es in Google Earth auch so zu sehen ist, zumindest war das so bei den Archiven von diesen Satellitenbildanbietern immer zu sehen, weil die halt sich konstant gegenseitig halt immer fotografieren, weil die halt sehen wollen, was die mit ihren Küsteninstallationen da treiben. Also da, so die Auflösung, die man da so kriegen kann, ist halt in der Regel so ein Meter ungefähr. Das halt so, das was da so rausfällt. Und also Meterschwarz-Weiß, 4 Meter Farbe. Also das heißt, die Farbe, die Farbinformation ist nicht ein Meter scharf, sondern nur 4 Meter scharf. Aber die Pixelinformation ist halt ein Meter scharf darunter. Und jetzt die neueren Satelliten, die jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob die schon oben sind, demnächst hochgehen, haben dann sowas wie 33, 35 Zentimeter Auflösung. Damit kann man halt schon signifikante Dinge sehen. Also das halt schon richtig...
33 Zentimeter pro Pixel.
Also 3 Pixel pro Meter, da kann man halt schon echt viel sehen.
So ein Auto kann man abbilden. Wir haben einen Anruf an. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Die Frage an euch ist, was macht ihr so mit eurem Navigationsgerät? Anton? Was machst du so mit deinem Navigationsgerät?
Es geht mir jetzt eigentlich gar nicht darum, was ich jetzt damit mache. Ich habe gerade nur ein Tom Thomas Auto und da geht es mir eigentlich ums Galileo-System. Ich wollte jetzt mal nachfragen, wird das eigentlich später, ist das gedacht, dass das auch militärisch genutzt wird?
Es gibt auch eine Frequenz bzw. ein Signal auf dem Galileo-System, was eine sehr hohe Genauigkeit und sehr hohe Verfügbarkeit hat, was erstmal als nicht öffentliches Signal deklariert ist, aber es ist einigermaßen klar, dass es sich dabei um das Signal handelt, was dann vom Militär verwendet wird.
Ja, aber wenn man jetzt mal darüber nachdenkt, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wer Indien oder China, also jetzt gerade Länder, wo man jetzt solch Militärische jetzt, China wie gesagt, die haben ja schon so einen Teil, aber ja was für China selber, oder?
Ja, es ist nur China und die Nachbarschaft, genau.
Aber jetzt Indien, speziell Land, das jetzt auch Atomwaffen hat oder so, ob das jetzt da recht legendisch, wenn man den nachher so, wenn die das nachher schlussendlich auch militärisch nutzen dürfen, oder soll das nachher militärisch nur für EU-Länder verwendet, weil das geht ja von der EU aus.
Militärisch nutzen werden das bestimmt jeder, der in irgendeiner Form militärisch unterwegs ist. Die Frage ist nur, ob er die besseren oder die schlechteren Daten hat.
Also ich meine, bei einer Megatonne ist irgendwie der Unterschied zwischen einem und zehn Metern echt irrelevant. Das glaube ich auch. Also um es mal ganz trocken zu formulieren. Also insofern, ist halt klar, dass halt irgendwie alle Verteilen halt irgendwie sowohl zivil als auch militärisch verwenden werden. Also da gibt es halt kaum Zweifel dran. Das ist halt auch der Grund, warum die da halt alle mitmachen.
Kannst du jetzt zum Beispiel also zu irgendeinem Land, zu den Amerikanern gehen und sagen, ich kaufe mir jetzt eine Lizenz für euer GPS-System, für militärische Nutzung und kriegt dafür genauere Daten. Also das kann Deutschland eigentlich, oder verwendet es Deutschland?
Wir würden jetzt gerne in Schweden angreifen, gebt uns mal ordentliche Daten für Schweden.
Nein, es geht halt um die Genauigkeit des Positionssignals. Es ist halt so, dass die militärischen Empfänger, da gibt es halt wiederum auch verschiedene Stufen und Genauigkeiten, die rücken die Amerikaner nicht so gerne raus. Also in der Regel sind die halt nur für das amerikanische Militär, partiell halt für NATO-Staaten, aber auch nur unter gewissen Bedingungen. Und häufig ist es auch so, dass die halt, wenn es halt keine zwingende Notwendigkeit gibt, die ganz präzisen Empfänger rauszurücken, dann drücken sie denen halt einfach Empfänger für zu viele Frequenzen in die Hand. Der Grund ist halt, dass sie halt verhindern wollen, dass halt ein Land, was sie irgendwo mal angreifen wollen, halt die militärischen Frequenzen stören kann und auch das militärische Signal stören kann und damit halt Präzisionswaffen, wie halt zum Beispiel GPS-gesteuerte Bomben, halt ablenken kann. Deswegen ist bei denen halt auch so der Versuch, halt einfach dieses militärische Signal möglichst unter einem geringen Nutzerkreis zu halten und das halt nicht allzu weit zu verbreiten. Im Endeffekt ist da mal der Unterschied zwischen, wie gesagt, einem Meter beim militärischen Signal und vielleicht irgendwie drei bis fünf Meter für ein augmented ziviles Signal nicht mehr so dramatisch, wenn man halt irgendwie von größeren Sprengmitteln ausgeht. Insofern wird das auch immer relevanter, diese ganze Voodoo-Dinähe, die da rum machen.
Also jetzt, so wie jetzt die Amerikaner sagen, also wenn jetzt das GPS-System in der militärischen Nutzung bis auf einen guten Meter genau ist, dann kann man eigentlich den Amerikanern das glauben, was sie sagen, in der Hinsicht, dass ihre Arm-Raketen ein Fenster treffen, dass man die durch ein Fenster reinjagen kann.
Also davon kann man ausgehen.
Aber man hatte das öfter gesehen, und dass das eben nicht funktioniert.
Das Problem ist halt, man muss halt einfach wissen, wo das Fenster ist, das ist glaube ich das größte Problem. Also ich meine, da gab es halt lustige Geschichten. Zum Beispiel der jetzige Präsident von Afghanistan, als er nur knapp vorbeigeschafft an einem Problem, das entstanden war, als die Amerikaner GPS-basierte Bomben verwendet haben bei ihrem Angriff auf Afghanistan. Und ich hätte das glaube ich mal für einen Darwin Award nominiert, und das wurde dann aber gelöscht. Was passiert war folgendet, die... Die Amerikaner haben halt sogenannte Forward Fire oder Forward Air Controller. Dabei handelt es sich um Leute, die dann wirklich nah an den Feind ran müssen. Und die haben halt einen GPS-Empfänger und an den GPS-Empfänger ist ein Laser-Entfarnungsmesser gekoppelt.
Das sind wieder diese Laser-Pieces, die man in Hollywood-Streifen sieht.
Nee, nee, das muss man auch erzählen. Das ist ein bisschen komplexer. Also was halt passiert ist folgendet, wenn man halt die GPS-Position eines Ziels halt nicht genau erfassen kann, indem man da hingeht und seinen Empfänger hindert und den Knopf drückt, stellt man sich halt ein bisschen weiter weg, da wo man noch sicher stehen kann, ist die eigene Position, dann hat man diesen Laser-Entfernungsmesser, der misst halt die Entfernung und die Richtung und den Höhnenwinkel zum Ziel. Und dann wird halt in dem GPS-Empfänger sozusagen der Offset ausgerechnet. Also mit diesem Laser kann man auf einen Meter genau die Entfernung dahin messen und den Winkel mit dem Kompass und so weiter und so fort. Und daraus kann man recht einfach die Position ausrichten. Was jetzt passiert ist, die haben, also dieser Carzell war halt zusammen mit so einem Forward Air Controller da unterwegs und noch irgendwie ein paar von seinen Mannen und sie wollten halt nun die Taliban da platt machen. Und sie hatten halt auch irgendwie einen Bomber in der Luft. Also alles schön. Und haben halt das Ziel erfasst. Und dann fielen die Batterien aus in den GPS-Empfänger. Und zwar bevor der das hoch übertragen konnte. Dann haben sie halt neue Batterien da reingesteckt. Und dann war halt aber der Offset weg. Das stand auch im Manual. Also da stand halt auch im Handbuch drin so, wenn du neue Batterien reinsetzt, ist der Offset, also diese Abweichung, die da durch die Nähe sein kann, weg.
Dann haben sie einfach ihre eigene Position übertragen?
Dann haben sie ihre eigene Position übertragen. Und sie haben es irgendwie so noch so eine Sekunde vorher oder so gemerkt, dass irgendwie, als das irgendwie so dann halt losging, es gab da diverse Tote und irgendwie der Kasei ist da irgendwie nur so gerade so davongekommen, also der war halt irgendwie dabei.
Also das Ding ging eigentlich auf sie selber los?
Ja, es ging, sie haben sich sozusagen selber getroffen, weil sie haben halt ihre eigene Position übertragen, weil halt dieser Offset zum Ziel halt nicht übertragen wurde.
Dann war die Waffe intelligenter als der Schütze.
Das war halt passiert, der hat halt oben da tippa tippa tippa klack und weg damit. Wie gesagt, diese Positionsermittlung, also wo ist denn das Ziel eigentlich? Das ist häufig das eigentliche Problem. Es gibt da tausende Randprobleme, so angefangen von Kartenprojektionen. Also wo ist denn ein Objekt tatsächlich auf der Erdoberfläche mit GPS, wenn die Karte halt eine andere Projektion hat als das GPS-System? Also sozusagen die Erde ist dann nicht eine Kugel, sondern eine Kartoffel. Also so ein bäulige Ding, wenn man sich das mal tatsächlich anguckt. Und da gibt es halt gewisse idealisierende Annäherungen an diese Bäule. Das ist der sogenannte Ellipsoid. Davon gibt es halt auch wieder verschiedene. Und der Standard-Ellipsoid für GPS ist halt WGS84. Und was dann halt passiert ist, dass das halt eine Idealisierung sind. Die haben halt nicht jede winzige kleine Bäule da tatsächlich mit erfasst. Und das führt halt dann tatsächlich zur Abweichung zwischen Karte und Realität. Die sind halt nur ein paar Meter. Aber wenn du wirklich in so ein Fenster schießen willst, dann ist der eine Meter links oder rechts tatsächlich von Bedeutung so. Dann passiert noch so Sachen, dass die Leute sich schlicht vertippen. Also dass sie sich bei der Übertragung von Zielkoordinaten einfach schlichten ergreifend vertippen.
Mit Zahlenstoß drinnen.
Genau, mit Zahlen, Dreher, was auch immer so. Also was passiert halt einfach so in der Hitze des Gefechts, wie man so schön sagt.
Kann man ja Wikipedia auch gerade schön beobachten. Da sind auch diverse griechische Orte mitten im Atlantik getaggt worden.
Oder hier der geostationäre Satellit, den wir gerade hatten, der gerade bei Flugzeughöhe hing.
Genau, da wurde einfach mal Faktor 10 falsch berechnet worden.
Also da passieren halt einfach Fehler. Also wenn man sich halt so dermaßen auf die Hightech verlässt, die man halt mit diesem Navigationssystem hat, dann ist das halt schon eine ziemlich coole Angelegenheit. Man kann halt eine Position auf der Erdoberfläche bestimmen und vor allen Dingen wiederfinden. Und die Übertragung in die Karten ist dann sozusagen der nächste Schritt.
Ja, jetzt tun wir schnell was anderes. Und zwar auch nochmal wechseln Galileo. Und zwar hab ich ja mal gehört, dass das System eigentlich auch als... Also es ist ja als Gegenstück klar zum GPS-System gebaut worden. Dass das aber nachher, also dass es auch dafür gedacht ist, zu meiner Unabhängigkeit zu diesem amerikanischen System zu haben, weil nämlich ansich könnte in einem großen Kriegsfall die Amerikaner einfach das Ding abdrehen für alle anderen. Dann hat es bloß noch ihr Militär und die anderen machen eigentlich durch die Bank den Flug, sozusagen. Also dann würde damit mit Navigationen an sich recht wenig laufen. Ich finde so, dass jetzt der Hintergedanke in dem Galileo-System eigentlich darauf betrifft, dass man sich von diesem GPS-System abwendet, um eine eigene Absicherung zu haben.
Das ist sicherlich die wesentliche Motivation. Also was halt der Grund ist, ist halt ein Komplexer. Also zum einen ist natürlich jede Menge Industriepolitik dabei. Zum anderen wollen die Europäer unabhängig von den Amerikanern sein. Dit wiederum ist aber auch wieder ein Bestandteil eines komplexen Agreements. Also zum Beispiel haben die Amerikaner gesagt, okay, die bösen Terroristen sind um uns und sie werden auch irgendwann GPS verwenden und sie werden irgendwann kleine Flugzeuge nehmen und der GPS reinschrauben und uns alle mit Giftgas besprühen oder was auch immer, sich das so vorstellen. Und deswegen müssen sie, sagen sie, in der Lage sein, auch Galileo zu stören. Und da gab es halt ein langes Hin und Her. Was halt damit geendet ist, dass sie halt ein Abkommen getroffen haben, was sozusagen sagt, die Europäer können GPS stören und die Amerikaner können Galileo stören. Aber in einer Art und Weise, die halt das, zumindest bei Galileo, das normale zivile Signal erhält, also um halt einfach den, da nicht Flugzeug abstürzen zu lassen, wenn man halt irgendwie den Terroristen halt, die die Fähigkeit nehmen will, halt da irgendwie Giftgas durch die Gegend zu sprühen, GPS gesteuert oder so.
Also läuft das, also läuft in Ansicht des militärischen Galileo nicht, also unabhängig vom zivilen Galileo nicht, wenn man ja bloß das eingestören kann.
So ist zumindest die Spezifikation, wie tatsächlich denn eine Realität aussieht, wenn wir sehen, sobald das oben ist. Also kann man gerade noch nicht so viel sagen. Gibt halt erstmal Experimentalsatelliten, werden wir halt einfach mal sehen.
Und ist das System sowas, ist das System vom Aufbau her komplett anders als die GPS?
Nee, ist halt sehr ähnlich wie GPS, aber sie haben halt aus den vielen Erfahrungen gelernt, die da gemacht wurden. Es hat halt eine höhere Sendeleistung und verwendet eine moderne Modulationsart, was bedeutet, dass man halt mit derselben Sendeleistung noch einen besseren Empfang bekommt. Es hat außerdem noch einen Datenübertragungskanal, über den das halt zusätzliche Informationen übertragen werden können, zum Beispiel Stauinformation und so ein ganzer Kram. Und es gibt halt nicht nur diese Trennung zwischen normalen Zivilen-Signalen und dem Militärischen Signal, sondern es gibt halt auch noch verschiedene Abstufungen des sogenannten kommerziellen Signals, was halt eine höhere Verfügbarkeit, eine höhere Sendeleistung hat, mit dem man halt zum Beispiel Flugzeuge sicher landen lassen kann und ähnliche Dinge.
0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Nummer. Fragen beantworten wir natürlich auch gern, würden aber auch ganz gern von euch wissen. Was ihr mit euren Navigationsgerätschaften so anstellt, den lieben langen Tag lang, kann ja nicht sein, dass ihr einfach nur durch die Gegenfahrt und durch die Flugzeuge...
Wir können ja mal ein bisschen erzählen, was andere Leute so machen.
Was ich super finde, ist das Degree Confluence Project, wo einfach Leute, die über ein Navigationssystem verfügen, sich an die Schnittpunkte von ganzen Längen- und Breitengraden begeben und das fotografieren, wie es da aussieht.
Und wie viele sind da schon zusammengekommen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele schon zusammengekommen sind. Auf der Webseite steht Confluence Org, ist die Adresse. Auf der Webseite steht, dass noch 11.543 Schnittpunkte offen sind.
Gerade aller Länder vereinigt euch.
Ah, hier, warte mal, 6.440 sind bisher fotografiert worden. Fotografiert worden, genau.
Von?
Von wie von.
Von wie vielen?
Da mussten es ja 16.000 ungefähr sein.
11.000 sind noch übrig?
11.543 sind noch offen, 4.640 sind, ne, 15.000.
Also 30 Prozent, was auch immer. Und, ist hübsch da?
Ist hübsch da. Also Brandenburg ist auch was dabei.
Ja, Fotos und GPS, das sind natürlich schonmal so ein Ding. Also eine der aktuellen Hypes ist das Geotagging von Fotos. Und da gibt es mittlerweile auch die notwendigen Standards. Ich muss zugeben, ich hab da selber noch nicht so richtig viel mit rumgespielt, deswegen kann ich wenig praktische Handlungsanweisungen geben, aber es gibt da eine ganze Menge interessanter Ressourcen. Allen voran natürlich Flickr, die das jetzt wohl recht einfach machen. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man sein Foto veröffentlicht, veröffentlicht man mit dem Foto als Metainformation auch noch die Position. Und Flickr bietet eben auch dritten dann wiederum diese Datenpfeil, sodass es eben schon eine ganze Menge interessante integrierte Dienste gibt. Zum Beispiel in den Links hier in unserem Chaosradio-Wiki gibt es auch diese Yuan Maps, was ist denn im Yuan Maps CC oder so, irgendwie sowas, wo im Prinzip alles, was auf bestimmten Diensten, unter anderem Flickr, aber nicht nur Flickr, geotaggt ist, dann auch direkt in so ein Google Maps Card mit eingeblendet wird. Das heißt, man kann dann eben so im Webbrowser über die Welt rübergehen und man sieht dann eben auch Fotos an dem Ort. Das ist jetzt eigentlich so der Trend. Man nimmt einfach alles, was sich in irgendeiner Form auf einen bestimmten Ort bezieht. Das ist bei Fotos natürlich eine ganz natürliche Sache. Aber eben auch so Gebäude, Stadtinformationen, was auch immer, historische Orte. Und versucht die halt in irgendeiner Form mit dieser Meta-Information der Geoposition zu versehen. Und speichert das in irgendeiner Form, sodass eben Dritte das mit ihren Tools wiederum kombinieren können. Und da ist gerade Google Earth eine wunderbare Plattform. Also ich habe in den letzten Wochen ein bisschen zu viel Zeit damit verbracht, weil ich einfach auch so ein paar Dienste komplett hängen geblieben bin. Und so spannend. Allen voran gibt es eine ganz hervorragende Wikipedia-Integration. Also seit einiger Zeit ist ja das Geotagging der Wikipedia schon ganz gut vorangekommen. Insbesondere in der Deutschen, muss man sagen. Da ist sehr viel Arbeit geleistet worden. Aber auch in der Englischen gibt es einiges. Die anderen sind dann auch ein bisschen hinterher. Das heißt, es gibt ein Standard, wie man für einen Artikel, die damit assoziierte Geokoordinate in den Artikel reinschreibt. Da gibt es auch ausführliche Seiten auf der Wikipedia, wo das alles beschrieben wird. Dann steht die Information da drin. Jetzt gibt es verschiedene Dienste. Am beeindruckendsten fand ich den... Oh Gott, jetzt habe ich den Link nicht parat. Ich kann das gleich noch mal raussuchen. Auf jeden Fall ist das ein Dienst, wo ich mir einen Google Earth Network Link besorgen kann. Das ist auch auf der Georeferenzierungsseite in der Wikipedia erläutert. Das bedeutet, ich klicke da einmal auf diesen Google Earth Link. Das ist diese sogenannte KMZ-Datei oder KML. KML ist diese Auszeichnungssprache, die Keyhole Markup Language, eine XML-basierte Sprache, in der man Placemarks ausdrücken kann. Also hier ist ein Ort, hier ist eine Region, hier sind Pfade, damit kann man Linien und Flächen malen, alles Mögliche, auch Gebäude, aber vor allem auch einzelne Punkte markieren. Was aber auch geht, ist, dass man in diesen Dingern sagt, ok, ich bin selbst noch gar keine Geoinformation, sondern ich sag dir nur, wo du sie regelmäßig abholen kannst. Das heißt, da steht dann eine URL drin und während ich durch meinen Google Earth irgendwo hinfliege, holt er sich eben aktuelle Informationen aus dem Netz von einem Server. Genau das gibt es eben mit diesen Wikipedia-Daten. Das heißt, man kann sich jeden Artikel, der in der Wikipedia gegeotaggt ist, automatisch während man mit Google Earth irgendwo lang fliegt, an der Stelle einblenden lassen. Und das ist total prima. Also man fliegt irgendwie über Deutschland. Man hat zu jedem Kaff mit einem Klick den passenden Wikipedia-Artikel dazu. Man sieht natürlich auch die ganzen Artikel zu Landmarks, zu Schlössern, zu was auch immer. Historischen Hinweisen, was auch immer. Und in dem Moment, wo man in der Wikipedia für einen Artikel eine dazugehörige Geokoordinat mit einträgt, führt das dazu, dass es dann eben bei dem nächsten Batch läuft. Also das ist nicht in Echtzeit, sondern die müssen halt immer mal wieder die Wikipedia, den ganzen Damp auslesen, das parsen und dann in ein neues Format überführen, damit die das eben live machen können. Aber während ich halt in Google Earth fliege, sehe ich halt immer den letzten Stand direkt. Und das ist einfach mal total spannend.
Und Luft holen! Das Chaos Radio 116 ist hier. Und der Blue Moon lässt sich anrufen unter 03317797160. Und das hat Christian gemacht. Hallo, Christian.
Hallo, ich hab jetzt hier, man hat ja auch schon Navigation vor Satelliten gemacht. Und ich hätte jetzt hier bei einem Sender des VR-Systems, den hätte ich jetzt hier auf meinem Radio. Ich könnte es euch durchgeben.
Wie, was, was?
Hab ich auch gerade nicht verstanden.
Nochmal, das war Systems.
Entschuldigung, ich bin da besser aufgeregt. Ja, also es gibt ja im Flugbereich, also für Flugzeuge, stimmt, gibt es das VR-System und ich hab jetzt hier gerade auf meinem Radio, hätte ich da jetzt gerade einen Sender eingestellt.
Ja, mach doch mal an.
Was ist denn bitte das VR-System? Ja, ich kann es hören, aber ich kann es nicht dekodieren.
Im Morse-Code ist es die Kennung des Senders und es wird zusätzlich auch noch irgendwie die Himmelsrichtung des Empfängers gegenüber des Senders angegeben.
Also VR steht für Very High Frequency Omni-Range Navigation oder auch UKW Drehfunkfeuer, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
UKW Drehfunkfeuer, das hört sich schön an.
Ja, das ist in der Tat ein sehr hübsches System. Man stellt halt die Frequenz von dem Funkfeuer ein, das man haben möchte und dann gibt es in dem Flugzeug selber tatsächlich so eine Rahmendreh-Antenne, die man halt dreht und der zeigt dann an die Kompassrichtung zu diesem Flugfeuer an.
Eigentlich die Richtung vom Funkfeuer. Die Antenne muss gar nicht drehbar sein im Empfängnis.
War es doch bei den frühen Geräten, war das doch glaube ich so. Ja stimmt, ist sogar tatsächlich noch in Verwendung. Also die Piloten fliegen natürlich auch alle heutzutage mit GPS, aber diese Systeme sind auch immer noch gerade so in vielen kleineren Flugzeugen doch noch zu finden. Ja, vielen Dank, das ist ja doch herrlich.
Danke schön Christian. Gute Nacht, tschüss. 0331 77 97 110 vielleicht habt ihr ja auch noch ein Signal gefunden, mit dem man navigieren kann, das wir noch nicht gehört haben, wenn wir nicht im Radio. Chaosradio 116, es geht um Ortungssysteme.
Wir haben gerade festgestellt, dass Holli, Hollis billige Armanduhr bestimmt nicht so billig war, wie sie aussieht.
Nee, eigentlich kann sie, die sieht ja gar nicht billig aus. Die war ja runtergesetzt, also um sehr viel. Und ich hatte mich schon gewundert, warum das überhaupt so ist. Aber jetzt weiß ich natürlich, warum.
Genau. Ja, jetzt haben sie dich am Arm.
So, Tim, noch ein bisschen Paranoia hinzuzufügen?
Ja, na ja, erst mal noch so ein bisschen der Spaß, den man haben kann. Also ich hatte vor allem jetzt ein bisschen Spaß mit Google Earth. Neben diesem Wikipedia-Link gibt es natürlich auch noch eine ganze Menge andere Sachen. Also es gibt diese, also gerade diese Network-Links sind natürlich prima. Zum Beispiel gab es vor kurzem während der Tour de France auch ein so ein Google Earth Network-Link, wo man immer das Peloton, also den Rennverlauf in Realtime mitverfolgen konnte. Da die ja sowieso die ganze Zeit mit ihren Motorrädern da dran vorbeifahren, haben die offensichtlich auch eine korrekte GPS-Messung aller Fahrer. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt auf den, also offensichtlich ist es nicht auf einen einzelnen Fahrer bezogen, aber sie haben zumindest die Spitze und das Peloton, also dieses folgende Hauptfeld. Ich glaube, wir haben das nicht verwechselt. Peloton ist doch das Hauptfeld, oder?
Ey, frag mich nicht zu Sport.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall war das ganz putzig zu sehen, weil man hatte einschließlich Berge immer so den aktuellen Punkt. Man konnte auch schön einstellen, ob man das von vorne oder von hinten oder von oben oder von ganz weit weg anschauen lassen möchte. Leider waren die Satelliten- und Luftbilddaten von Frankreich ziemlich mies, sodass es nur an wenigen Stellen wirklich schick aussah. Aber da hat man schon mal gesehen, was man so mit Realtime-Tracking machen kann.
Was ich ja toll finden würde, wenn sie dann einfach immer so das Logo des Pharma-Sponsors über den Fahrer einblenden würden, so dann könnten sie einfach mal...
Es führt gerade Telekom.
Ach, Telekom, so Roche oder wie auch immer.
Ach so.
Das ist doch Pharma-Olympics da jetzt bei der Tour de France. Und dann könnten sie doch eigentlich gleich die Logos auf die T-Shirts drucken und dann weiß man, was man das nächste Jahr so schlucken muss, wenn man auch vorne mit dabei sein soll.
Schneller in den Bergen mit...
Genau.
Ja, ungeahnt Möglichkeiten. Was ich auch sehr schön finde, bei Open APRS gibt es eine Realtime-Visualisierung für Google Earth aller Satelliten. Wobei ich die, die muss man ein bisschen so salz nehmen, weil wir haben vorhin mal überprüft, so die Geo-Satelliten, das war nämlich genau das, was du vorhin angesprochen hast, da waren die irgendwie so um Faktor 10 zu niedrig. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich da einfach nur vertan haben oder ob das aus Visuellen...
Sie sah aus wie ein Vertipper...
.sah echt aus wie ein Vertipper. Also die sind einfach viel zu niedrig für geostationäre Satelliten. Aber dort kann man halt auch alles sehen, also Amateur-Satelliten, die ganzen Profisatelliten, geostationäre Satelliten, Fernsehsatelliten und so richtig schön ausführlich, wo die gerade sind, was sie für ein Sichtfeld haben und was eben sonst noch an Daten dazu eingeblendet werden kann. Dann gibt es bei fboweb.com ganz schick Real-Time-Visualisierung von anfliegenden Flugzeugen für bestimmte amerikanische Flughäfen. Das heißt, man sagt irgendwie, ja, mich interessiert das Thema San Francisco. Ja, das wollen wir alle für Europa haben, aber du weißt ja, wie das ist. Sowas gibt es dann zuerst immer nur in den USA, weil wir ja hier so technikfeindlich sind und immer erstmal fragen, wogegen das verwendet werden kann und welche Nachteile uns in der Zukunft das bringen.
Dazu kommen wir natürlich auch noch gleich.
Und es gibt noch ein Networklink für die ISS. Also alles, was sich auf der Erde bewegt und um die Erde herum, das lässt sich halt in Google Earth prima einblenden. Und mit diesen Networklinks geht es eben besonders schick.
Ich lese gerade in Regensburg auf der Papstmesse wollen Schwangere ihre Kinder gebären.
Können wir das irgendwie taggen?
Irgendwie ist diese Welt schon so ein bisschen komisch.
Ich hatte ja noch einen Nachtrag zu deiner Kartengeschichte und den Anbietern. Was kosten eigentlich diese Karten?
Was ist da deine Vorstellung?
Da wird halt viel Geheimnis drum gemacht. Also ist halt so, dass der Anteil, lass mich so ausdrücken, ich glaube ich darf es nicht so genau sagen. Anyway, wenn du halt so ein Navigationssystem kaufst, ist halt so ein Tom-Tom-Auto-Dingeldong oder so, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass so ungefähr so ein bisschen unter 10% des Preises von dem Gerät geht halt an diese Kartenlieferanten. Das ist halt so ein ganz grober Anhaltspunkt, den sie da so ausgeben. Das ist also schon ein recht signifikanter Beitrag zu dem Gesamtpreis dieses Gerätes.
Und freie Projekte gibt es ein paar. Das Einzige, was ich jetzt kenne, ist dieses Open-Street-Map-Projekt. Das ist halt so für Leute, die sowieso durch die Stadt latschen und ein GPS-Gerät haben. Die können halt solche Tracks machen und haben da, glaube ich, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das funktioniert, haben die ja gleich so eine Software, wo sie das dann live annotieren können.
Es gibt halt verschiedene Versuche, dieses Duphol von Teleratlas und Nachttech zu unterwandern. Das Problem ist halt, dass die, die verlangen halt immer Geld. Das heißt, es gibt halt keine gute Möglichkeit, an diese Geodaten halt für laut zu kommen. Man kann sie halt hoffentlich aus städtischen Daten extrahieren. Also es gibt zum Beispiel beim Berliner Senat gibt es irgendwie so ein tolles Pfeil. Das ist ein Höhenmodell von Berlin, wo man halt so das Berliner Urstromtal sieht. Und wenn man da so ein bisschen reinzoomt und reinzoomt und reinzoomt, das ist ein gigantisches PDF, irgendwie so 8 Megabyte PDF. Und dann zoomt man da so ein bisschen rein und stellt man fest, dass da noch ein kompletter Straßenlayer drin ist. Nochmal alle Straßen reingerendert und beschriftet.
Das ist nett.
Das kann man sich dann da so raus extrahieren. Das ist ganz nett. Also man kriegt halt, muss halt ein bisschen suchen, so viel seine Stadt findet man schon immer. Irgendwas Problem ist halt, wie die Rechte denn für diese Karten-Daten aussehen, ist halt immer fragwürdig und schwierig. Deswegen halt diese Versuche mit Leuten, die halt einfach Straßen lang laufen und die hinterher beschriften und sagen, es ist halt die Straße und es ist halt die Straße, halt so eine freie Kartenbasis zu schaffen. Das ist halt extrem mühsam. Also es ist halt wirklich richtig doll viel Arbeit. Und es gibt halt diese OpenStreetMap-Projekte. Es gibt noch irgendein anderes Projekt, was ich irgendwie dauernd umbenennt. Das ist ein aktueller Name irgendwie leider.
Es gibt ja auch noch Wikimaps. Also aus dem Wikipedia-Bereich. Ich habe allerdings keine rechte Ahnung, wie weit das ist.
Also die OpenStreetMap hat halt den Vorteil, dass es halt ein stahlisches Datenformat gibt, wo man halt einfach mit eigener Software randocken kann und halt irgendwie Sachen machen kann. Aber es ist halt schwierig, also soweit man halt anfängt, zum Beispiel andere Kartendaten nachzuklicken, läuft man halt immer Gefahr, dass man wiederum deren Rechte verletzt. Also dieser ganze Rechtegewirr ist halt in diesem ganzen Geodatenmarkt halt extrem. Also da geht halt auch viel Geld über den Tisch für diese Geodaten. Zum Beispiel so Sammlungen von so Points of Interest, also halt irgendwie Restaurants mit Öffnungszeiten oder ähnlichen Dingen, gehen halt für ziemlich viel Geld über den Tisch, die halt dann zum Beispiel in so einem Navigationssystem drin sind. Dass du da so einen Knopf hast, wo du sagen kannst, ich will ins Hotel. Und dann kommt halt die Liste der Hotels im Umkreis. Also diese Umkreissuche wird halt immer wichtiger. Und dann werden natürlich die Suchergebnisplätze in diesen Navigationssystem verkauft, um halt irgendwie mehr Leute ins Hotel zu kriegen. Also all den ganzen Kram, den man halt bei Google hat, wird man nämlich jetzt halt auch auf diesen...
Die haben natürlich auch ein echtes Copyright-Problem. Ich erinnere mich gerade an den Vortrag über dieses Open-Street-Map, den ich gesehen habe vor ein paar Monaten. Dann meinte er, die hätten halt bei ihren Erfassungen der Stadt auch festgestellt, dass eben viele Karten Fehler haben. Das heißt, da sind da einfach mal überall so kleine Einfahrten, die es nicht gibt oder die sind da nicht drin oder so. Also es werden überall ganz bewusst kleine Fehler eingebaut, anhand derer sie dann wiederum erkennen können, wenn andere ihre Karten kopiert haben. Weil sie ganz offensichtlich die Fehler eben mitkopiert haben, die sie ja wohl kaum gehabt hätten, wenn sie selber die Daten so erfasst hätten.
Poor Man's Watermark.
Ja, das ist in dem Bereich sehr üblich. Auch bei diesen Point-of-Interest-Sammlungen oder einfach bei normalen Adress-Sammlungen zum Beispiel. Von einigen Ländern gibt es mittlerweile geokordierte Adressen. Das heißt also tatsächlich von jedem Hauseingang eine Geokoordinate. Du kannst jede Adresse tatsächlich eine präzise Koordinate zu anderen. Von anderen Ländern gibt es nur so gerechnete Adressen. Das heißt, die nehmen die Länge des Straßenabschnitts von einer Kurve bis zur nächsten und nehmen die Anzahl der Hausnummern und teilen die Strecke durch die Anzahl der Hausnummern.
In Japan würde das nicht funktionieren.
In Japan gibt es eh keine Adressentausendnummern.
In Japan gibt es schon ganz klare Zuordnungen. Die steht nur in den Datenbanken von den Behörden. Jedes Haus hat tatsächlich eine ID, bloß dass die in keiner Form fortlaufen, sondern nur fortlaufen in der Vergabe. Das heißt, du baust ein neues Haus und bekommst die nächste aufsteigende Nummer.
Napoleon hat das auch gemacht. Daher kommt 4711, weil 4711 war das Haus 4711 in Köln damals unter Napoleon. Ja, gab's bei uns auch mal so ein Wahnsinn.
Heute noch in Japan live zu bestaunen. Aber was du meinst, mit Leuten, die mit GPS rumlaufen und es schwierig ist und erfangen. Es gibt ja eine Menge, die das tun. Kannst du vielleicht mal ein bisschen was zu diesem Geocaching-Movement sagen? Du hast das ja auch schon mal ausprobiert.
Geocaching ist sozusagen ein richtiger Nordsport. Es funktioniert folgendermaßen. Man braucht ein GPS, eine kleine Plastikkiste oder ein Weckglas, ein kleines Notizbuch, ein Bleistift und ein bisschen Plastik-Schrödel, so irgendwie Gummibärchen oder Flummis oder irgendein Zeug. Was man tut ist, man geht halt in den Wald oder irgendwo anders, wo man es nett findet. Und da versteckt man halt diese Kiste. Und aus dem Notizbuch wird ein Logbuch, den Bleistift schmeißt man da rein, damit Leute, die diese Kiste finden, reinschreiben können, dass sie da waren. Und ein bisschen Plastik-Schrödel sind halt so symbolische Gegenstände, die man halt reintut, die man rausnehmen kann und wieder woanders reintun kann. Dann nimmt man so ein GPS und zeichnet die Koordinate von diesem sogenannten Geocache auf. Man versteckt ihn halt so ein bisschen, dass er nicht ganz offensichtlich zu sehen ist. Und die tut man dann halt bei so einer Webseite, es gibt halt verschiedene, so Free Caching, Geocaching, Geocaching kommen, glaube ich, die ersten. Tut man die dahin und dann wartet man darauf, dass jemand die findet. Das funktioniert halt voll und am meisten. Man sucht sich halt einen Cache auf dieser Webseite raus, hat dann die Geo-Koordinate von diesem Cache und tippt die halt in seinen GPS und geht dann halt einfach raus und versucht, die zu finden. Und das Interessante daran ist, dass die Koordinaten halt nie richtig doll präzise sind. Also das ist halt nur mal so 5 Meter auf oder 10 Meter oder so. Und wenn man sich jetzt so ein Gebiet von 10 mal 10 Meter im Wald vorstellt, da kann man schon ganz schön suchen, bis man dann tatsächlich so eine kleine blaue Plastikkiste oder so gefunden hat. Da hat man dann noch eine Menge Spaß und da gibt es dann immer noch so Hinweise, man muss irgendwie Dinge heben oder um die Ecke gucken oder sollte etwas größer sein oder so. Manche Geocache sind halt auch an echt richtig doll schwierigen Stellen versteckt. Also es gibt zum Beispiel irgendwie einen im Berliner Hauptbahnhof, dessen Beschreibung war so in der Richtung, man sollte lieber in einer großen Gruppe hingehen, dass die anderen sich drum herum stellen können, während einer den Cache birgt. Dann gibt es auch wieder andere Caches, die sind oben in New York auf Hochhäusern, oben auf dem Dach, wo man nicht hinkommt, da muss man dann auch eine Tür picken oder so. Also das ist halt schon so richtig wild. Da gibt es mittlerweile mehrere hunderttausend von diesen Geocaches.
Gibt es eine zentrale Seite dazu?
Es gibt halt geocaching.com, das ist halt der größte Anbieter. Man kann mal auf geocaching.de gehen, das ist die deutsche Seite.
Da gibt es noch Open Caching oder so.
Genau, Geocaching.de integriert halt so ein bisschen diese ganzen Caching-Seiten. Das wird für Deutschland. Geocaching.de wird lustigerweise unterstützt von der deutschen Wandervogel-Bewegung.
Durch die Deutsche Wanderjugend.
Wanderjugend, ja genau.
Das ist doch super, das ist ein einstagener Grund, mal wieder ins Freie zu gehen.
Das dachten die sich wahrscheinlich auch. Was bei Geocaching toll ist, ist, man versteckt halt so einen Cache und kriegt halt laufende Mails von irgendwelchen Leuten, von irgendwo aus der Welt, die den gefunden haben, weil sie gerade in der Gegend waren. Zum anderen kann man halt losgehen und halt Sachen finden. Und eines der Phänomene beim Geocaching sind unsere Travel Bugs. Dabei handelt es sich um kleine Gegenstände, die eine Nummer haben, die man auf dieser Webseite registriert und die halt von einem Cache zum anderen wandern. Das heißt, man nimmt sie aus einem Cache raus und tut sie in einen anderen Cache rein. Und da kann dann halt mal so ein Geo-Tech aus Tokio halt irgendwie in einem Cache in Fensterwalde landen. Und dann wandert der Geo-Bug halt irgendwie weiter nach Australien. Da hab ich alles schon gesehen, ist alles passiert so. Da hat man doch eine ganze Menge Spaß und Bewegung dabei. Und so bei den etwas populären Caches, die halt so in Berliner Umland relativ leicht zu erreichen sind, trifft man auch lauter andere Verrückte, die dann halt irgendwie so mit leicht starrem Blick so ihr GPS vor sich gehalten durch den Wald stolpern. Da weiß man dann schon so, ah Geo-Cacher. Da gibt es dann so unausgesprochene Protokolle, so wie er als erster näher dran ist, hat er dann halt das erste Recht, den Cache zu finden. Und der andere hält sich dann so ein bisschen weg, sodass er nicht sieht, wo der Cache verbuddelt oder versteckt ist, damit er dann auch noch den Spaß haben kann. Also es ist halt nicht selten, dass so beliebte Caches fünf oder sechsmal am Tag gefunden werden, bei schönem Wetter. Das ist eigentlich so ein sehr schöner Aspekt von diesem ganzen GPS-Spiel.
Ja, da gibt es natürlich noch ein paar unschöne Aspekte, aber wo man sicherlich auch nochmal zu sprechen kommen sollte. Definitiv Anwendungen, wo man sich so mindestens mal ein Stirnrunzeln produzieren sollte. Zum Beispiel diese Hausarrest-Geschichte.
Die virtuelle Fußfessel hier.
Die virtuelle Fußfessel, genau, da kriegt man halt so ein Bannchen.
Ist das realistisch oder ist das schon bei Paranoia?
Das wird getan.
Das wird schon getan.
Das ist in den USA eins der Mittel.
Also angefangen hat es halt mit diesen Dingern, die halt einen Hausarrest überwachen. Du kriegst halt einen kleinen Sender in deinen Schlafzimmerschrank installiert. Und das Ding macht halt Radau, wenn die Fußfessel außerhalb des Bereichs von diesem Sender ist. Also die kommunizieren miteinander. Und dann gibt es jetzt für verschiedene Straftäter halt so eine Fußfesseln, die verhindern sollen, dass sie sich in bestimmte Gebiete bewegen. Also halt irgendwie so speziell, wenn sie so eine Restraining Order oder sowas haben, dass sie halt ein bestimmtes Gebiet nicht aufsuchen dürfen.
Snake-Plesking.
Genau, dass sie sich halt nicht in die Nähe einer Schule trauen dürfen oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und da wird halt ihre Position permanent überwacht. Und halt in der Zentrale mitgeteilt. Und wenn sie da halt verstoßen, ist es halt ein Verstoß gegen die Bewegungsauflagen. Das heißt also, was da passiert ist, dass die Menschen halt in der Tat die ganze Zeit getrackt werden und halt ihre Bewegungen halt eingeschränkt werden. Man kann halt geteilter Meinung darüber sein, es ist halt schlecht besser, als wenn sie im Knast sitzen müssen. Ja, aber das halt...
Macht aber auch den Anreiz zu einer einschränkenden Verurteilung sehr viel einfacher.
Genau, also es hat halt alles seine Vor- und Nachteile so. Also ich meine, GPS-Tracker sind mittlerweile z.B. in vielen Mietwagen drinnen, die halt dann einfach nicht mehr gehen, wenn man in die polnische Grenze fährt. Dann geht halt einfach das Auto aus. Und das Ding sagt halt übersatiliert Bescheid, übrigens ich bin gerade irgendwie in Polen oder kurz vor der polnischen Grenze.
Oder es wird halt auch fern abgeschaltet.
Genau, passiert halt auch. Diese GPS-Tracker gibt es natürlich auch noch in verschiedensten Bauformen, z.B. halt auch für Ermittlungsbehörden, wo halt das Bundesverfassungsgericht die Schranken für die Anwendung halt sehr niedrig gesetzt hat. Die haben halt gesagt, naja, da liegt halt nicht dem Schutz, den halt z.B. der Wohnraum unterliegt. Das heißt also, die Polizei kann halt mit relativ geringen Schranken halt jemandem so einen GPS-Tracker halt unter das Auto kleben und halt seine gesamten Bewegungen verfolgen. Also was halt da drin ist, ist halt ein Mobiltelefon und ein GPS-Empfänger. Und die Positionsinformation aus dem GPS-Empfänger wird halt laufend über das Mobiltelefon weggeschickt. Und wird halt versorgt aus der Speisespannung vom Auto, aus dem Bordnetz oder halt mit einer eigenen Batterie. Klebt halt typischerweise in dieser Plastikstoßstange drinnen. Die billigsten Dinger davon kosten mittlerweile so um die 500 Euro. Also ist halt irgendwie keine echte Investition mehr. Und findet halt immer weitere Anwendungen. Also häufig werden halt auch Container damit getrackt oder Waren-Sendungen, die halt ein bisschen mehr wert sind. Also bis hin zu, dass das halt in so einfach so Paletten integriert wird, wo halt z.B. Palette Mobiltelefon oder dergleichen Dinge mehr, wo man halt so eine halbe Million oder so auf so einer Palette drauf hat. Die werden ganz standardmäßig getrackt. Da wollen die halt wissen, wo ist diese Palette gerade so. Und wenn die halt auf einem LKW sind, diese LKWs sind hinten meistens irgendwie eh nur aus Plaste. Das heißt, da hat man auch recht guten Empfang. Und dann senden die Dinge halt periodisch ihre Positionsinformationen. Oder zum Beispiel kann man auch einen Alarm konfigurieren. Das heißt, man gibt halt einen Corridor vor, in dem sich diese Sendung bewegen darf. Und wenn die Sendung diesen Corridor verlässt, dann geht halt der Alarm los, weil das ein Anzeichen dafür ist, dass sie jetzt gerade geklaut wurde oder dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Der Chat meint übrigens, die Preise werden schon auf 300 bis 200 Euro runter.
Ja, also für Aktive habe ich noch nicht so billig gesehen. Auf der Cebit gab es ein paar, die dafür gedacht waren, dass man sie in Teddybären stopft, damit man irgendwie seine Kinder trecken kann oder dass irgendwie der Oma in die Köttelschürze stopfen kann, falls die halt mal verloren geht. Also diese Verbreitung von diesen Technologien wird halt in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren dramatisch werden. Einfach bedingt dadurch, dass die Technologie klein geworden ist und noch wenig Strom verbraucht. Also wie gesagt, dieser Streichholzschachtelgroße Empfänger hier ist so ein 50-Euro-Dingelchen von Ebay halt irgendwie made in China so billig, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Da jetzt noch irgendwie so billig, wie es nur irgendwie geht, Mobiltelefon ranzuschnitzen, ist halt irgendwie kein großer Akt. Und dann ist man halt wirklich bei so einem 100-Dollar-Ding, was halt permanent die Position, seine Position überträgt. Und da geht halt die Reise, sag ich mal, auch im privaten Bereich. Also es gibt halt die erste Firma, die sowas für Hunde verkauft. Also das ist halt ein Hundehalsband, was halt permanent die Position überträgt.
Für unsere Kleinen.
Genau.
Für unseren besten Freund.
Genau. Damit er halt irgendwie nicht fremd geht oder verloren geht.
Ja genau, das ist nämlich jetzt auch ein Ding. Ich glaube, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass die ganzen Geodienste recht schnell in unsere Alltagselektronik Einzug halten wird. Allen voran unser Mobiltelefon. Es gibt eine neue Technik, das hatten wir glaube ich vorhin noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Assisted GPS.
Das nennt sich genau Assisted GPS oder kurz A-GPS. Das ist eine Methode, wie man sein Mobiltelefon zur Ortung verwenden kann, ohne einen vollständigen GPS-Receiver drin zu haben und auch ohne weiteres Sichtkontakt haben zu müssen. Das funktioniert so, dass der Großteil der Berechnung gar nicht von dem eigenen Gerät durchgeführt wird, sondern das macht das Netz für mich. Das heißt, mein Telefonnetz weiß ja immer, wo ich eingebucht bin. Es gibt also immer eine Zelle, mit der ich in Kontakt stehe und von der kann ich ja nicht sehr weit weg sein. Wie weit weg weiß die Zelle ja selber, kann sie unter Umständen auch noch anhand der Signalstärke...
Ach so, die Zelle weiß anhand der Signalstärke, wie weit ich vom Massen entferne.
Kann, ja, sie ist nicht unbedingt auf einen Zentimeter genau, aber so Pi mal Daumen schon. Wie groß ist die Zelle?
Das hängt davon ab, wo man ist. In der Stadt ist eine typische Einkaufszentrum Zelle nur 150 Meter Radius. Auf einem flachen Land, wo wenig los ist, wenig Autobahnen sind, können es bis zu 26 Kilometer sein. Und dazwischen bewegt sich total so. Technisch gesehen ist es so, dass die Zellen in den 1800 MHz Netzen, also E+, zum Beispiel, und O2 kleiner sind, und die in den 900 MHz Netzen, also D1 und D2, größer sind. Aber da die auch wiederum jeweils andere Frequenzen dazugekauft haben, sind nur noch so eine grobe Faustregel. Aber in der Stadt geht es halt genauer, auf dem Land geht es weniger genauer, so die grobe Faustregel.
Und es gibt ja auch schon länger diese Geschichte mit Lokalisierung nur über das Eingebuchtsein. Man ist ja auch selten nur von einer Zelle sichtbar, sondern man erwartet ja geradezu von dem Netz, dass man nahtlose Übergänge hat, auch wenn man mit der Autobahn fährt. Das heißt, es gibt dieses Handover, wo man von einer Zelle zur nächsten weitergereicht wird. Das findet natürlich so statt, dass ich eben immer von mehreren gesehen werde, also von 2n oder vielleicht auch mal von 3n. Und wenn es eben auch 3 sind, gleichzeitig die mich sehen, dann ist es sogar sehr einfach über die Signalstärke, wenn man diese Daten hat. Also das fällt jetzt im laufenden Betrieb nicht so automatisch ab. Aber wenn man diese Daten mitspeichert, wenn man jetzt eine Person ganz konkret überwacht zum Beispiel und eben keine der Zellen diese Daten wegwirft, dann kann man eben aus diesen relativ genau schon messen, wo es ist. Aber dieses A-GPS geht jetzt noch einen Schritt weiter, weil es eben selber die GPS-Satelliten beobachtet. Also jede Zelle schaut sich einfach den Himmel an und weiß eben einfach mal, wo die Satelliten sind. Und kann dann eben zusätzlich mit ein paar simplen Empfangsdaten, die das Telefon selber noch bereitstellt, also das Telefon ist wie ein GPS-Empfänger und schaut mal, was es so bekommt an Signalen, leitet das aber an das Netz weiter. Und das Netz führt die eigentliche Berechnung durch und das Netz weiß dann eben auch exakt, wo ich bin. Ich weiß nicht, wie genau wollen die da sein? Ist das so wie DGPS dann auch sozusagen enhanced?
Also das hängt halt natürlich wiederum von Empfangssituationen ab, also wie viel Himmel der Telefon sieht und so weiter und so fort. Aber die Vorgabe ist, dass es halt wesentlich besser als 50 Meter sein soll. Und unter guten Situationen kann man auch so drei Meter runterkommen.
Wir bitten um Aufmerksamkeit für eine kurze Veranstaltungsempfehlung von Radio Fritze Marco Seifert. Liebe Cottbuserinnen und Cottbusser, strömt am 9. September zahlreich in den Elias-Park am Stadion der Freundschaft. Euch erwartet ein feines Open Air, unter anderem mit Anajo.
Und ich selbst werde auch da sein.
Fritz präsentiert das Open Air mit Mia und Anajo. September im Elias-Park am Stadion der Freundschaft in Cottbuss.
Ja und wie gesagt, ich bin da auch auf der Bühne.
Und im Radio...
Im Atomstreit mit dem Iran wollen die USA so rasch wie möglich über Sanktionen diskutieren, falls die Führung in Teheran nicht doch noch in letzter Minute einlenken sollte. Ausnahmssprecher McCormick sagte in Washington, bereits die erste Resolution müsse ein beachtliches Signal an den Iran senden, dass es sich um eine ernsthafte Sache handle. Danach müsse der Druck auf die Führung in Teheran Schritt für Schritt erhöht werden. Energieexperten rechnen nach der jüngsten Entscheidung der Bundesnetzagentur nicht mit deutlich sinkenden Strom- und Gaspreisen. Im besten Fall werde es eine sehr geringe Entlastung geben, sagte ein Sprecher des Bundes der Energieverbraucher. Die deutschen Stadtwerke gehen sogar von weiter steigenden Strompreisen aus. Das Hamburger Unternehmen Conergy will in der leerstehenden Chipfabrikhalle in Frankfurt-Oder Solartechnik produzieren. Mittelfristig könnten bis zu 1000 Arbeitsplätze entstehen, berichten mehrere Zeitungen unter Berufung auf einen Unternehmenssprecher. Förderanträge für das Vorhaben seien bereits gestellt. Mehrere Billigfluganbieter haben die Planung für den Großflughafen Berlin Brandenburg international kritisiert. Neun Billigfluglinien drohten gemeinsam mit ihrem Rückzug aus Berlin. In einem Appell heißt es, die Planung für den Flughafen sei nur auf die traditionellen und teuren Fluggesellschaften wie Lufthansa ausgerichtet. Andere internationale Flughäfen würden den Billigfliegern eigene abgetrennte Terminals zur Verfügung stellen. Dies sei in Berlin nicht der Fall. Heute Nacht soll es regnen, bei Tiefstwerten um 13 bis 10 Grad. Am Tag wird es wolkig, aber auch mal heiter, bei Höchstwerten um 21 Grad. Mit keinen aktuellen Meldungen, überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, 5 nach halb 1.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
Berlin, 30. April 1945. Die Welt brennt, Deutschland liegt in Schutt und Asche und in Japan geht es auch nicht mehr so gut. Aber einer lässt sich nicht unterkriegen. Im Führerbunker brennt noch Licht.
Ich hacke meinen Bunker mitten in Berlin. Ich habe blaue Säurekapseln und genug Benzin. Die Luftwaffe ist furchtbar, die Marine das Heer der zweite Weltkrieg. Keiner hört mehr auf mich, jeder macht, was er will und hinter allem steckt dieser Churchill. No, I don't surrender this Churchill. I don't surrender.
I don't surrender.
I don't surrender. I don't surrender.
I don't surrender. I don't surrender. Ja, mehr gibt's nicht.
Adolf die Nazisau, ne?
Aus dem Buch, der war hinten drin, der Bonkar.
Genau, von Walter Müllers. Gesungen von Pigor, ein ganz großartiger Künstler, den ich vergangenes Jahr, glaube ich, war das in der BAI, da von uns gesehen habe, mit der Show Pigor singt und Eichhorn muss begleiten, Volumen 3. Der gibt so seinen Shows immer mal Volumen 1, Volumen 2, Volumen 3, der macht aber immer dasselbe. Das merkt man dann auch erst, wenn man zum dritten Mal dasselbe gesehen hat. Sehr, sehr lustig.
Pigor singt und Benedikt Eichhorn muss begleiten.
Und der mittlerweile voll integrierte Ulf oder so ähnlich war dann auch noch dabei. Oder wie hieß der Ulf?
Der Ulf.
Der Ulf, genau, mittlerweile voll integriert.
Sagt Wikipedia, Pigor und Eichhorn ist das Stichwort.
Gut, also gut hingehen. Prima, wenn die Eltern in Berlin sind, war so Großstadt Kleinkunst.
Wir haben hier auch Kultur.
Genau. Guck nur, Mutter.
Ja, und du hast hier Nordrhein-Westfalen angeguckt, Feugin?
Ja, das war bei geocaching.de. Nordrhein-Westfalen war gepflastert mit kleinen grünen Tupfen.
Und jetzt kaufst du morgen GPS-Empfänger und holst dir das Valentinsbonus-Cache.
Genau, aber vor allem in der Sonne schenken.
Ja, ansonsten noch so ein bisschen bei der, wohin geht denn die Reise so mit dem ganzen GPS-Tracking.
Alle werden sich im Internet ausziehen und sich live irgendwie übertragen. Also nicht nur aufnehmen und per MySpace stand im Spiel. Und YouTube, ja ja. Also ich denke mal, das ist so die nächste Entblößung. Und wir werden uns dann schon ein bisschen an den Anblick gewinnen müssen, dass alle, zumindest einige Leute, sehr viel Spuren hinterlassen. Das ist ja auch nicht ganz unpopulär jetzt schon.
Also das Problem ist halt, dass im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen Dingen kann man halt eine Lokation schwierig bewegen. Also kriegen ja so Prominente schon mit, wenn halt deren Häuser oder was auch immer, halt irgendwie in Google oder wo auch immer verdartet werden. Und die halt aber eigentlich gerne ihre Privatsphäre haben wollen, also die halt eigentlich nicht wollen, dass irgendwie jeder weiß, wo sie wohnen. Es ist halt extrem schwer rückgängig zu machen. So man kann dann halt im extremsten Fall eigentlich nur umziehen. Also weil so eine Lokation wechseln ist halt nun mal...
Oder einen großen Zaun drumherum bauen.
Ja, aber selbst das ist ja manchmal irgendwie... also es ist halt diese Transparenzmachung des physikalischen Raums, das ist ja das, worum es geht. Also auch die datenmäßige Erschließung der realen Welt ist ja eigentlich sozusagen das Kernthema dabei.
Aber auch Real-Time Stalking kommt so in Mode. Da gab es auch diese Webseite, wo sie irgendwie in Echtzeit die Geocoordinaten von irgendwelchen Celebrities von jemanden gesehen wurden veröffentlichten. Das finde ich auch schön hart.
Ja, aber je nachdem, wie viel Millionen die verdienen, kann man damit gut leben, glaube ich.
Du meinst, du wirst für so ein paar Millionen nicht auch...
Weiß ich nicht.
Stell dir mal vor, du wärst populär.
Stell dir vor, du wärst Per-Syth-en.
Nee, ja, dann hätte ich keinen Spaß mehr beim Sex. Also ich weiß nicht, habt ihr das Video gesehen? Welches? Sie kann nicht singen, sie kann nicht Schauspieler und wer den Film gesehen hat, weiß, sie kann andere Sachen auch nicht. Ganz schlimm, ist nicht von mir, der Satz ist von Dennis Leary.
So, so, du stiebst mal wieder alles ab. Also du bist nicht Per-Syth-en, aber ich bin genommen, du wärst jetzt irgendwie populär. Das geht dir bestimmt schnell auf den Sack, wenn du an welche Leute die ganze Zeit hier herhörst.
Ich begebe mich doch freiwillig dahin. Ich begebe mich doch freiwillig dahin. Es ist doch nicht so, dass ich populär werde durch Zufall, sondern es ist so, dass ich populär werde, weil ich das will. Na ja schon, bei dem denn nicht. Also wenn du so John Travolters Haus da siehst, weiß ich nicht.
Na ja, Leute, die von der Bill-Seitung in die Öffentlichkeit gezerrt werden und dann...
Das finde ich aber auch nicht Popularität.
Das hat Recht und Opfer, na ja gut, aber auch da setzt man das Stalking ein.
Du sprachst ja von Celebrities. Das finde ich wirklich völlig unproblematisch. Also wer das nicht will, kann sich zurückziehen. Die Möglichkeit gibt es immer.
Weiß ich nicht, ob man sich da noch zurückziehen kann, wenn man die ganze Zeit live getrackt wird.
www.radiomoderatorentracking.com Natürlich, du kannst dich aus der Popularität zurückziehen. Also du musst das nicht tun. Das ist so. Das meine ich damit. Klar, wenn die Bild-Zeitung dann irgendjemand in die Öffentlichkeit zerrt, das ist natürlich, das ist furchtbar.
Das ist ganz furchtbar. Du wirst aber halt tatsächlich durch relativ kleine Datenpreisgrammen in der virtuellen Welt zu ziemlich inversiven Handlungen in der realen Welt gezwungen. Das ist halt das, was passiert. Irgendjemand postet halt irgendwie die Geokoordinate von deiner Wohnung und schon hast du die ganzen Groupies da rumhängen. Oder was auch immer. Oder die Leute, keine Ahnung, denen du den Betrieb zugemacht hast. Das geht halt so einigermaßen in alle Richtungen. Das heißt, seine Privatsphäre zu bewahren, wird halt einfach wesentlich schwieriger. Möglicherweise wissen dann viele Leute auch einfach nicht, wie ihn geschieht. Weil sie gar nicht wissen, in welchem komischen, obskuren Forum jetzt gerade plötzlich ihre Koordinaten gepostet wurden.
Ich meine, wenn es nicht die Privatsphäre ist, dann ist es auf jeden Fall die Arbeitswelt, wo ich auch noch ein gewisses Potenzial sehe.
Bei Taxifahrern mag es ja noch nachvollziehbar sein, aber so Bauarbeiter, Außendienstmitarbeiter, LKW-Fahrer sind komplett getrackt, Außendienstmitarbeiter, Handelsvertreter sind mittlerweile auch ziemlich auf dem Vormarsch, dass deren Routen optimiert werden und die auf der Basis ihrer momentanen Position noch aktuelle Requests reinbekommen. Service-Mitarbeiter, also Leute, die irgendwelche Sachen reparieren, werden halt auch weitestgehend über GPS-basierte Systeme dispatchen mittlerweile. Also alles, wo halt Leute sich bewegen, also viel bewegen, um halt von einem Arbeitsort zum anderen zu kommen, findet halt Trecken statt. Polizisten mittlerweile auch, also in etlichen Städten, werden die Fahrzeugkoordinaten von den Polizeifahrzeugen tatsächlich übertragen.
Was aber? Gut, das hat ja...
Also kann man so oder so sehen, die Polizisten...
Wohin wird es denn übertragen? Kann ich das dann auch in Google erst?
Zur Zentrale erst mal, falls du dann noch in Google auskriegst, ist noch eine andere Frage. Also da passiert eine Menge. Zum Beispiel die BVG weiß halt, wo jedes ihrer Fahrzeuge ist. Und zwar genau. Und die machen darauf basierend halt ihr Fahrplanmanagement. Das heißt, der Operator hat so eine Konsole, wo er halt ein Netz draufsieht. Und dann sind halt die Fahrzeuge, sind dann halt irgendwie rot, grün und gelb eingefärbt. Wobei sehr lustig ist, ist anders als man denken würde. Grün ist okay, gelb ist zu spät und rot ist zu früh. Weil für so einen Verkehrsmittel- benutzer ist zu früh viel schlimmer als zu spät. Weil zu früh verpasst halt der Zug und deswegen muss bremsen, muss bremsen, genau. Und die übertragen die Daten halt dann über Tetra, also über ein Funksystem. Das ist halt schon recht ausgereiftet und hübsches System. Ist es nicht diese Polizeifunk-Technik? Ist der selbe Standard. Der wird aber auch an Industrie schon häufig verwendet.
Ist denn bei diesem Polizeifunk auch die Geo-Übermittlung mit dabei?
Na klar, also die Geräte können alle GPS haben. Dann wissen sie halt auch wo der individuelle Feuer heran ist.
Ich hab zu Hause irgendwo noch zwei so Walkie Talkies rumfliegen, die GPS haben. Ich glaub die können sogar auch übertragen, wo sie sind.
Diese Reno-Dinge?
Ich weiß nicht, die darf man hier glaube ich gar nicht benutzen.
Die haben sie ja im Irak-Krieg verwendet, um sich nicht gegenseitig zu erschießen. Ernsthaft? Da haben sie teilweise bei den Infanterieeinheiten diese Dinge ausgegeben, die halt unverschüsslich die Positionen broadcasten, weil sie dachten, die Irakis sind eh zu blöd. Damit sie sich halt nicht gegenseitig erschießen, wenn sie da irgendwie im Gelände rumkrabbeln, weil du auf dem Display sehen kannst, wo halt die anderen Leute von deiner Einheit sind.
Ich glaube aber so sophisticated ist das nicht, was ich da habe.
Du siehst halt nur so Punkte da reingemalt, ne?
Nee, der übermittelt einfach, wenn du auf senden drückst, einfach deine Koordinaten.
Die kannst du dir aber auch aufs Display malen lassen, oder nicht?
Nee, nee, das ist tatsächlich so.
Zahlen?
Zahlen.
Ah, okay, vielleicht hast du noch die Option noch nicht gefunden?
Nee, das ist einfach billiger alter Scheiß.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Das gibt es jetzt auch mit irgendwie grafischem Dingeldong und dann kann man sagen, wie du dich dahin malen lassen.
Gibt es denn schon, kennst du schon Mobiltelefone, die jetzt GPS auch, also ich weiß, dass es GSM-Telefone mit GPS gibt schon lange, aber gibt es das irgendwie im Mainstream-Bereich bereits?
Also der, was jetzt gerade passiert ist, dass halt für einen sehr populären Chipsatz, aus dem halt Mobiltelefone gebaut werden, die Kosten für ein GPS dazumachen, auf 2, 40 Euro bei 100.000er-Stückzahlen gesunken sind. Also der Unterschied zwischen einem Telefon mit GPS und einem Telefon ohne GPS ist bei signifikanten Stückzahlen für den Hersteller 2, 40 Euro, plus ein bisschen mehr Handbuchdrucken. Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen, dass es jetzt so, denke ich mal, 2007 wird so ein Jahr sein, wo GPS richtig in den Mainstream geht bei den Telefonen. Bisher war das Problem, dass das noch recht viel Strom verbraucht hat, deswegen halt nicht so populär war und sie halt auch den Markt nicht gesehen haben. Aber so 2007, beziehungsweise schon Ende dieses Jahres, werden halt sehr viele Mobiltelefone mit eingebauten, GPS mit eingebauten, Navigationen, Karten, Online-Update, was immer du dir vorstellen kannst, auf den Markt kommen soll. Das geht jetzt halt so richtig los, weil es halt einfach billig wird und sie halt das Stromversorgungsproblem gelöst haben.
Ich habe bei eBay gerade ein Ortungssystem, GSM GPS mit Surf 3 für 600 Euro. Schön so all in one, also schönes kleines Gerät.
So ein Magnet unter die Stoßstange, ein Platscher.
5, 99 Euro.
Das ist noch eher so ein bisschen teurer.
Krissi ist auch billiger.
Ja, mit Vertrag, ne, Krissi Billigen.
Also der Vertrag bei wem? Kann man dann den Geheimdienst ankreuzen?
Also die Sache mit dem GPS und dem Mainstream, die wird da halt ganz dramatisch losgehen. Also was ich so höre, woran die Operator und auch die Hersteller so arbeiten, sind halt so Sachen wie Integration mit halt diesen großen Mainstream-Block Sites. Also halt, wie sie alle heißen, halt irgendwie Post-My-Picture-auf-Rosa-Hintergrund-Sites für die ganzen Kiddies, die halt direkt mit dem Mobiltelefon zu integrieren, um halt da auch einfach das, was du sagtest, zum Beispiel Flickr mit GPS-Position und so. Die Telefone haben halt ein GPS, die haben eine Kamera, die haben halt direkte Online-Kapazitäten, das heißt, die ist dann halt auf dem Knopfdruck. Hier bin ich und irgendwie, da ist das Foto, was ich hier geschossen habe, und es ist direkt gleich im Flicker drin.
Oh, Kinder, da fällt mir auch ein, da gibt es ja auch wieder so diverse Leute, die der Meinung sind, die eigenen Kinder die ganze Zeit per GPS überwachen, wäre auch eine gute Idee.
Wie gesagt, gibt es auch schon so Teddy-Beer mit GPS-Build-In.
Der dann auch regelmäßig ein Foto schießt und das hochflickert, ne?
Ja, das wird es dann vermutlich geben, ja.
Und irgendwann bist du ja erwachsen und denkst dir, scheiße, was ist denn hier los, warum stehen hier überall Leute rum?
Genau.
Aber beneidenswert finde ich natürlich so die Vision, dass man so heutzutage als Neumensch die Möglichkeit hat, doch mit relativ sparsam Einsatz von Equipment im Prinzip sein ganzes Leben komplett zu tracken. Also wenn ich jetzt mal so die Taste drücken könnte, bitte einmal kompletter GPS-Track von wo auch immer ich gerade war, wo ich lang gelaufen bin. Ich versuche jetzt gerade so meine Reisen der letzten 20 Jahre auf Google Earth nachzuvollziehen. Das ist schon ganz schön anstrengend. Aber macht aber natürlich wiederum mehr Spaß, als wenn ich nur in der Linie abfliegen würde. Ich will so ein Telefon haben mit GPS, Frank. Wo gibt es das? Was kostet das?
Na, wirst du noch zu Weihnachten alles kaufen können.
Echt? Ach echt?
Ach, das ist doch so schön.
Was geht jetzt hier los?
Wie passend auch.
Ja, was mach ich jetzt? Hol ich mir jetzt einen Tom-Tom oder warte ich noch bis Weihnachten?
So und dann schmeißt man halt irgendwie dem Weihnachtsmann so einen Trecker in den Schlitten.
Oder mach ich beides.
Ja, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen wenig von euch gehört leider. Also ich hätte ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen mehr erwartet, weil es gibt doch eigentlich schon eine ganze Menge, die sich mit GPS in irgendeiner Form beschäftigen. Es gibt ja einige lustige. Du hast auch mal so ein Projekt gemacht, Frank, mit dem Rucksack.
Das Urban Jungle Pack, das hat nicht nur Frank, sondern es hat auch Frank und ich. Also ich hab's da getrennt.
Ich hab's gebaut. Du warst der Operator.
Du hast echt der lang geladen?
Interessant war das Auswahlkriterium.
Genau.
Der sah am stabilsten aus.
Alle anderen fallen um damit. Obwohl für's Foto hatte, hatte die kleine Sarah das dann nochmal.
Genau. Also was der im Jungle Pack war, um's kurz zu erklären, war das Projekt, was wir damals bei Artcom gemacht haben. Es handelt sich um einen Rucksack mit einem Computer, der dafür damals gefallen ist, durchaus recht schnell war. Drei Mobiltelefone, GPS-Empfänger, eine Kamera, ein Headmounted Display und ein Kompass. Die Kamera und der Kompass waren in so ein Kopfding eingebaut, was der Holger auf dem Kopf hatte. Und wir konnten aus dem Rucksack raus Bilder von der Kamera komponiert übertragen. Audio vom Mikrofon. Wir konnten sehen, in welche Richtung der Holger guckt, mit dem Kompass und hatten die GPS-Position. Und haben das dann auf eine Webseite übertragen.
Und dann hat man gemacht, irgendwas, ziemlich einen Quatsch, eine Love Parade oder sowas.
Auf der Love Parade sind wir rumgelaufen, an dem Samstag, aber im Freitag davor auch.
Da hat man auch so ein Game gemacht, wie Rosen an Polizisten verschenken. Das war irgendwie so noch aus der Multimedia-Hyper-Hyper-Zeit.
Genau, als die Partys noch groß waren.
Genau, und das war dann durch das umfangreiche Akkus. Die Idee, die wir eigentlich hatten, war halt, sozusagen die Karte, die man halt, da hätte man auf dem Display der Heuge halt eine Karte, die hast du nie benutzt.
Naja, nicht wirklich, weil ich mich, ja, die war aber scheiße, die Karte.
Ja, das war auch so ein Problem, wir hatten keine Kartendaten. Also die Idee, die wir hatten, war halt, dass der Heuge durch die Brille durchguckt und halt sozusagen seine Umgebung kommentiert bekommt. Also dass es halt so Augmented Reality gibt, aber das war halt noch ein bisschen vor der Zeit da.
99, ja?
Das war ganz lustig, als wir uns da durch die Menge gequetscht haben und ich in diesen Rucksack hinten drauf hatte, der dann mittlerweile irgendwie 50 Grad erreicht hat und ich hab dann Raver-Verbrennen gespielt, das war ganz lustig.
Stimmt, und ich musste immer hinter ihm laufen, da hat ihm keiner mit einer Water-Sugar da reinballert und die... Der hat so riesige Lithium-Ionen-Akkus vorne dran, außer auf einer Kamera und da hat man echt Schiss, dass einer irgendwie einen Kurz schließt, weil dann wäre der Holger angefangen. Hab ich ihm da vorher nicht gesagt. Stimmt, das war zum ersten Mal. Das war doch...
Genau, da muss man...
Zurückgefahren sind wir mit Rikscha Nummer 23. Und der arme Rikscha-Fahrer. Frank war damals auch noch ein bisschen pfülliger.
Wir sind mit so einer Fahrrad-Rikscha, weil wir hatten keinen Bock mehr zurückzulaufen. Die Akkus waren alle und irgendwie waren durch.
Also ich hab das erste Mal, sagen wir jetzt, 2006, ich glaube, vor drei Jahren oder so, hab ich das gemacht beim Marathon.
Was? Das Jungle-Back beim Marathon angezogen?
Das war ein bisschen kleiner. Nee, ich bin einfach diesen Inline-Scale-Marathon mitgelaufen und dann hatte ich halt diese erste Generation von GSM-Telefonen mit eingebauten GPS drin.
Was dann halt per SMS die Position raus schickt?
Exakt, genau. Das heißt, hat nur einmal pro Minute die Position rausgeworfen, aber dann halt per SMS und dann gab es woanders in Berlin einen Computer, wo halt auch noch ein Telefon dran war, was diese SMS empfangen hat. Dann hat er einfach die Geokoordinate genommen und das dann wiederum in so einen Online-Stadtplan quasi mit eingeblendet. Dass man eben da auf der Webseite reloaden konnte und hatte dann eben auch immer die aktuelle Position oder die Seite hat sich glaube ich selber reloadet. Und jetzt könnte man das halt ganz prima mit Google Earth machen. Jetzt gibt es auch schon so ein bisschen Software.
Deine Marathon-Strecke über Google Earth?
Genau, weil jetzt kann man das halt so machen, dass man so ein Stück Java einfach ins Telefon wirft. Das liest ja eben diese Bluetooth-GPS-Ding live aus, holt sich die Koordinate raus, schickt das dann einfach per Datenpaket an Rechner XY und der wiederum macht den notwendigen KML-Code für Google Earth. Und dann kommt man es eben immer so live in Google Earth. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich das jetzt schaffe für den Marathon dieses Mal. Aber das wär eine nette Spielerei. Der ist Ende September.
Knapp.
Na, es läuft eigentlich schon.
Wir werden sehen.
Es ist nur so, dass manche Mobile-Funk-Provider offensichtlich UDP nicht so ohne Weiteres durchlassen. Also muss man sozusagen nochmal den passenden Provider dazu finden, die Software tut, aber die Dienstleistung ist mangelhaft.
Und damit endet Chaosradio 116.
Überortungssysteme. Jetzt haben wir uns ganz schön verortet.
Bisschen wenig Hörer.
Bis in die Orientierungslosigkeit. Genau, die erste reine Podcast-Live-Sendung.
Die hören morgen alle den Podcast.
Oh, jetzt ruf ich an.
Oh mein Simpsons, morgen den Podcast.
Da müssen wir nächstes Mal wieder ein interessantes Thema nehmen.
Chaosradio 117 am letzten Mittwoch im September.
Jetzt mit Thema.
Und zwar Wahlcomputer.
Hatten wir zwar letztes Mal schon angekündigt, musste aber dann um einen Monat verschoben werden, aber aus Termingründen, da war viel in den Urlaubszeiten.
Dann machen wir die Sendung über Wahlcomputer, wenn die Wahl gelaufen ist. Hätte da mal lieber nicht auf die Knöpfe gedeutet, hätte da mal lieber Briefwahl gelaufen.
Ja, die Wahl ist dann auch gelaufen, also die Wahl in Berlin ist dann gelaufen.
In Berlin gibt es keine Zugröße an Wahlmaschinen.
Da haben wir noch mal Glück gehabt.
Bei Berlin war Pleite genug.
Die könnten sich das gar nicht kaufen, selbst wenn sie wollten.
In Berlin ist so Pleite, da können sich keine Wahl kaufen.
Genau, aber warum es trotzdem eine dumme Idee wäre, sich solche zu kaufen, das werden wir in der nächsten Sendung ausführlich erläutern. Es kommen ja noch genug Wahlen. Außerdem ist Wann ist Wahl in den USA? Im November, glaube ich. Das wird auf jeden Fall noch ein heißes Thema sein. In Mexiko ist ja auch noch nicht alles gelaufen. In diesem Sinne, es grüßt das Chaosradio Team.
Schönen Abend noch.
Der Frank und der Holger.
Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit.